planet draft on y va avec ce soir allen
et nico vous les connaissez moi c'est
pierre on est parti
pour ce planet draft
donc tu avais remarqué beaucoup de
changements chez envergure notamment sur
la forme vous avez un article par jour
sur notre site envergure poing serré
jusqu'à la draft c'est la promesse qu'on
vous fait cette année une chaîne friche
caraïbes allait anne qui gère ça je
crois des podcasts sous un nouveau
format qui s'appelleront envergure
papote pour tous les détails sur ces
changements pour la saison 21 22 je ne
saurais que vous conseiller d'aller lire
le très bon article d'alex paru il ya un
mois soit envergure poids c'est où
planait draft donc c'est votre nouveau
rendez vous mensuel et en direction
envergure ce format pour but d'être
léger sur la forme et sol et sur le fond
mais surtout interactif donc on va
essayer au maximum de prendre des
questions du chat on compte donc sans
votre pertinence et l'utilisation d'un
langage approprié respectueux ça c'est
la base petit rappel ce petit rappel est
en fait pardon place au programme du
soir uniquement des prospects européens
hors de l'hexagone qui évoluent sur le
vieux continent première demi heure les
pépites européenne d'élus 16 ans suit un
focus sur un rêve hézard et nikolay au
beach
on enchaînera
sur la deuxième heure avec un débat
autour du draft h à savoir si c'est
encore une bonne formule ou pas pour
cela il y aura un agent de joueurs et un
journaliste de l'équipe on finira pas un
portrait d'un membre de l'équipe et
autres choux si nous avons encore un
petit peu de temps pour finir ces deux
heures on va passer ensemble en parlant
d'équipé envergure ce soir j'ai la
chance d'être à callas à la nique aux
îles son globe trotter il parle très
bien anglais ça va servir pour ce soir
mais sur l'année
alors on et fluence merci bien au ballon
et je tiens à présenter alan
la légende des pays savent bravo à la
bravo pour tout ce que tu fais pour tout
ce que tu es petit mozart du scouting
quand j'avais présenté à l'époque
surrender dogs
beaucoup trop mais merci à beaucoup
d'égards est vraiment plus tard et avec
vous ce soir donc mais si on attaque
directement sur les 8 16 vous êtes allé
les voir en direct live andrée et quels
sont les joueurs qui vous ont marqué
donc encore une fois je reprécise on
parle pas des joueurs français on aura
une émission sans doute spécialement
pour ça oui parce qu'on peut le dire les
deux meilleurs on va les trois des
meilleurs prospects sont français donc
du coup on va parler ce soir qu'il ya de
mal voyage sac hariri âgées et alexandre
sar pour ceux qui vivent dans une grotte
ces trois là on n'en parle pas ce soir
mais bien évidemment que alan et moi on
a kiffé d'aller en macédoine pour aller
pour aller les voir jouer contre on les
a vus contre la russie la lituanie
contre la lituanie complet
quentin lituanie avant on avait un peu
brumeux russie roumanie et oui c'est
vrai voilà incroyable
nico on va commencer avec toi tu voyais
ça deux joueurs un russe et un portugais
si je dis pas de bêtises on écoute tout
à fait pas je vais commencer par le
russe monte sarah mois il s'appelle et
gore et gore domine
on peut aussi dire et gore domine si on
n'aime vraiment
pas bien voilà donc c1 2006 il fait de
maître et jours on va dire au poste
arrière on pourrait dire meneur porte la
balle craie et en fait c'est ce que
j'aime chez lui au delà du fait qu'il a
quand même physique parfait pour un
prospect et ses 2 mètres il est long on
sent qu'il va encore continuer à grandir
il est fin
j'ai adoré le fond il a tout le pack à
tout le bagage technique et le dribble
être capable d'attaquer un pick and roll
être capable de faire jouer son équipe
peut être capable d'être dangereux près
du cercle de finir avec le contact pas
encore très sûre sur son tir d'ailleurs
le les trois premiers matchs sont
catastrophiques au niveau de l'adresse à
trois points et puis après il a un piano
oui pour tout te dire regardez regardez
les stats le premier match 0 sur 5 à
trois points contre la france il fait 2
sur 12 après fait 2 sur 8 donc ça te
fait un petit 4 sur 25 par contre pour
finir il finit à 9 sur 18
donc ça va venir ça va venir mais moi ce
que j'ai plus aimé chez lui
c'est que c'est un leader c'est que sur
le terrain c'est un patron il te place
tout le monde il connaît les systèmes
parker même quand c'est pas lui qui mène
la balle est là en train de corriger les
gros parce qu'on va le dire ce sont les
intérieurs qui sont perdus et donc voilà
c'est ce que j'ai aimé chez lui
ce que j'ai aimé aussi c'est la capacité
qui va ne pas se cacher en défense
attention on se calme on est sur un but
16 mai pour moi on est sur un tour et
player et c'est aussi ce qui me fait
vraiment kiffé chez lui il vient du
trenta sport academy qui est une
académie à moscou le papa était joueur
professionnel et il vient de signer au
real madrid encore un donc le real
madrid ils sont un peu en train de se
faire une équipe de
pros semaine pierre alain tu laisses tu
les as vu comme moi ils en auront au
moins 4,5 donc ça sera encore les
favoris pour les tournois early junior
clairement et mais en tout cas sur igor
de mines russes qui part en dehors de la
russie ça me plaît tout me plaît chez
c1 2006 en plus c'est pas un 2005 à
l'aller les u16 cette année c'était la
génération 2005 qu il était il fait de m
à son âge il a que 15 ans et vous
apprendre à concilier grandir ouais
franchement c'était un peu j'en étais
resté des projets dans l'équipe russe
n'était pas exceptionnelle point je
pensais qu'il avait peut-être des
joueurs un peu il ya d'autres joueurs
qu'il ya deux autres joueurs qui jouent
en espagne dans cette équipe
sanofi savent qu en a qui jouent à habas
konya et puis voronine je crois de
mémoire qui joue aussi en qui est pétri
de talent aussi mais qui est beaucoup
moins intéressant pour la nba et ouais
franchement bas il fait deux mètres il
peut de mettre à 15 ans
moi j'ai bien aimé voilà il va où il
veut sur le terrain à son âge pour ça
déjà c'est hyper intéressant et après
bon l'opposé le jour on l'a vu
l'opposition était voire exceptionnel
parce que la roumanie c'était vraiment
une équipe qui je pense ne pourrait pas
dû être aux multiples les pauvres ils
ont ils ont pris des valises des valises
si son parti sur ryanair ça a dû leur
coûter cher au retour
contre la france il y avait il y avait
je crois 34 à 2 à la fin d'un premier
quart-temps ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est ça 50 à 5 ou plus a donc en gros
c'était pas vraiment hyper intéressant
en fait mais alors on l'a que toi et moi
on l'a vu sur d'autres matches en vidéo
en vidéo voilà et c'est là où tu te dis
bon ya pas deux j'aime inutile j'aime
bien qui pique un petit clip vidéo de
lui je pense que j'ai peut-être allez
peut-être ne re tweeté ou un truc comme
ça comme ça les gens pourront voir on
voit notamment au tir faire de très
bonnes choses moi j'aimerais dans tout
type de position catch and shoot hot
spots up c'est tiger tu as raison de
préciser c'est à dire les tirs presque
pas qu'un tireur et dimensionnalité à
son âge c'est hyper hyper impressionnant
moi j'étais on était tous super
impressionné par lui en fait par sa
maîtrise son tempo son calme voilà je
connaissais pas je n'ai jamais entendu
parler j'ai tout de suite eu vraiment
apprécié et du coup ça peut pierre ça
peut être aussi quelque chose de négatif
c'est que moi je le trouve à sion battu
dans son jeu et du coup comment on
regarde comme un stage là on doit aussi
se dire qu'elle est là où est ce qu'ils
peuvent s'améliorer lui c'est sur la
régularité sur le tir le geste n'est pas
toujours le même et on va il un jeu à
risque donc c'est aussi pouvoir un peu
nettoyer tout ça
je te vois mais ya pas mal de balles
perdues froid sur son tournoi il à 3,6
je crois des mémoires un truc comme ça
donc ça fait quand même réfléchir c'est
pas des balles perdues sur le dribble
c'est vraiment parce que lui lui seul a
vu alors pour l'instant c'est des balles
perdues pour moi c'est le potentiel pour
finir en étant un superbe patients et en
sachant qui vu la taille qui lie finale
entre 2 5 et 2 10 donc c'est un gamin
qui va se rapprocher du cercle dont il
aura une capacité à créer pour les
autres qui sera titre exceptionnel le
fameux poème forward dont on parle
souvent mais qui existe rarement
finalement appuyé toutes les stats
franchement balles perdues moi je les
nuances sur tout ce qui lui 16 sont à
l'heure vous parleront comme l'adresse
club lance un tir à trois points bon
alors franchement à ce tu vois les
voiles et fade c'est horrible des fois
c'est affreux mais prononcé en se disant
que c'est des mecs qu'aucun des petits
qui ont 15 16 ans des fois il joue avec
des joueurs qui seront pas professionnel
je pense il joue contre des équipes qui
sont bien meilleurs qu'eux donc c'est à
nyon c'est pour ça qu'en fait si tu
regarde juste le c'est un travail
multiples parades et que le box corps il
faut aussi bas voir les matchs tu peux
aller aussi l'avantagé qu'on a eu c'est
de les voir à l'échauffement mais
meilleur mois voilà en vrai je
connaissais pas grand-chose de comment
on se compter sur place donc j'ai suivi
nico et est en fait pendant
l'échauffement d'apprendre énormément de
choses donc je le vois attiré beaucoup
plus que dans le match en fait bien sûr
à cet âge là c'est super intéressant
il par rapport donc on va rester sur
igor domine
justement fin mois dans la description
peu que vous en faites les légats
j'avais aussi justement ce côté très
cérébral etc etc est ce que il fait pas
aussi penser alors moi j'ai pensé à lui
dans lorsque vous me dire allez au à léo
westermann ce genre de power dans les
supers cérébrale qui pouvaient déjà
comme ça à cette époque là c'est vrai à
la pour avoir eu la chance de voir les
aussi vestas que je l'appelle le haut je
ne connais pas je
trouve j'ai trouvé igor plus dynamiques
sur peut-être un peu plus de 2 potentiel
athlétique
d'accord ok donc là c'était pour ton
psar de russie on ne va pas de chez vous
ou au deuxième donc c'est un portugais
l'aigle d asseoir sa cellule candidat
sort
c'est c'est ruben près dé olivera alors
qu'ils étaient connus sous le nom de
ruben olivera pendant l'euro ligue
junior avec j à l'entrée de manu avec un
salut les loubards qui m'a perturbé
salut renault j'espère que tu es encore
en vie
mais sinon
pour revenir sur ruben d'entre eux
viennent de oliveira quand il était à
valence pour leurs ligues juniors et
ruben prennent apparemment il a pris le
nom de sa maman
voilà on est sur un an n'est sur un
albatros à on est sur un joueur qui fait
de m 07 avec une envergure
de mémoire je crois qu'il est à 2 16 de
18 d'envergure
les stats - les stats elles parlent par
mm 17 points ok c'est le pourcentage il
est à 40 % donc c'est pas fou
par compte 18 rebonds voilà 10 18
rebonds 2 passes décisives au niveau des
contres on est à 5 contres de moyenne
bon ok c'est que dieu 16 on va dire que
c'est la division b ou de la division
sert il a joué à l'ukraine
la suisse la hongrie mais mine de rien
c'était pas des équipes dégueulasse à
part la hongrie on le dit à la hongrie
chypre occident il ya pas jouer chypre
pas lui sinon il a fait quatre matches
c'est le match et il n'a pas joué contre
la chine contre chip
et donc ok on j'ai ma fille qui est un
outil d'éducation regardant live merci
et donc pour pour ruben pour être un peu
plus sérieux moi ce que j'ai aimé déjà
c'est le corps s'ils l'ont ses fins par
contre on sent qu'il ya de la place au
niveau des épaules pour finir avec un
buste assez large intéressant la windpad
on en a parlé d'envergure elle est
vraiment impressionnant pour moi c'est
un
un corps élite pour devenir un big men
mais moderne
alors ok il a un coût un peu plus longue
la moyenne il a des hôtes en ch'ti
dédicace à notre ami
notre ami alex et
au début j'avais un peu peur parce que
je trouvais qu'il était utilisé comme un
comme un vieux pivot un coup d'écran je
roule des petits ou qu une activité puis
au final plus la compétition avançait et
plus il était capable de s'éloigner il
finira par avoir un tir à avoir une
reine à trois points pour l'instant vu
son âge et vu comment il a grandi c'est
un peu un peu compliqué après il ya des
il ya des flashes en défense il est
capable de switcher de défendre sur des
petits là dessus moi je mets un billet
sur le fait que ça sera vraiment un
élite défenseur vraiment pas seulement
une protection pas seulement dans la
raquette mais vraiment avec une capacité
à switcher
franchement j'ai écrit son scooter les
portes la semaine dernière donc il va
sortir cette semaine je pense
[Musique]
il est alors déjà il c'était un super
bizarrement il en a toujours
l'impression qu'il n'arrive pas à
respirer en fait
mais c'est parce qu'en fait et c'est ce
que j'ai mis le premier en fait dans le
scouting report c'est le mec qui l'a
joué 130 minutes en quatre matches alors
que c'est un intérieur à saison c'est
pas normal en fait c'est ça prouve déjà
qui n'a un coffre incroyable c'était le
mélangeur portugaise et des meilleurs
joueurs
s'étaient pas là en fait il faut le dire
aux gens ce qu'ils connaissent pas avec
des mines et rubén très on parle de
prospects bay
city c'est parce que c'était ok ouais on
parle de prospection parle de gars ruben
près dans la génération 2005 c'est à
dire qu'il pourrait se présenter en 2024
à la draft s'il le veut pour l'instant
c'est un prospect qui peut être au
premier tour franchement parce que c'est
un intérieur protecteur de ses retours
de contrôle il a dit bien de l'intérieur
bah oui mais parce qu'au premier tour au
premier tour c'est une pro c'est à dire
le niveau goût et parce qu'il protège le
cercle ouais c'est pas que la façade d
contre 8,21 contre encadrant quatre
matches c'est énorme c'est la dissuasion
aussi
parce qu'en fait il faut dire que 16 du
csb niveau moyen par contre franchement
des adhésions craignent un il y avait
des grands dans l'équipe d'ukraine y
avait des grands dans l'équipe
on voit vis à laon la suisse y en avait
un ou deux mais vraiment contre
l'ukraine il y avait des grands et donc
nous c'est toujours ce qu'on regarde
bien sûr s'il ya personne au dessus de 2
mètres brasse il va il va dominer il va
protéger leur il aura rien à faire pour
protéger le cercle là il y avait
vraiment des choses à faire donc côté
défensif il est vraiment bon il a peur
de rien il est un peu comme si je
compare pas un mais comme chez tom green
n'en a rien à faire de ce faire d'un
question en fait il va il va y aller à
la dissuasion à chaque fois il va
protéger j'attendais les protégés de
cirque à chaque fois et ensuite
offensivement il a pris des petits tirs
à trois points c'est à dire qu'il a pris
13 tirs à trois points il a pris du
midrange il a il a shooté à 14 heures 24
lancers francs c'est pas atroce
c'est pas trop franchement la mécanique
elle n'est pas exceptionnelle c'est un
peu cassée sur du c'ur du mil rennes
j'ai tout mais il a raison il a 16 ans
il dans une bonne et bâle il est en
championnat d'espagne qui joue à
badalone c'est là-haut nicolas vu pour
la première fois
à valence l'an dernier donc c'est un
portugais qui joue là bas il ya un des
deux parents qui vient du cap vert je
crois de mémoire et volvic mozambique
voilà donc une colonie portugaise
et c'était le mélangeur c'est le
meilleur joueur et c'est pas parce qu'il
est au portugal hub usb
que c'est pas un prospect des années
mais un skate à il a commencé madame
attention c'est pas la dives b1 c'était
plus ou moins mélanger cet été mais ya
pas de diva djbel à preuve la roumanie
s'est retrouvé avec la france donc le
porte qu'elle aurait pu se retrouver que
la france aussi complètement mais ils
ont joué des en fait il y avait trois
grosses foules quand même avec une poule
un peu en deçà à s'offrir pour ça qu'on
les a vus deux fois et malheureusement
des reposes avait un petit gymnase
plutôt qu'un gymnase plus plus grand
mais
non c'est vraiment un super joueur
offensivement le seul truc c'est qu'il
faut qu'il gagne en force c'est pour ça
qu'il a des pourcentages moyens parce
qu'en fait c'était un peu balancé il se
fait tancer quand il est proche du
cercle sachs et un intérieur qui est à
40 % aux tirs parce que il ya il avait
un peu plus de mal à finir proche du
poids une fois mais en fait il pourrait
tellement d'euros il pourrait tout temps
son rebond offensif ici battait tout le
temps auront enfin il a pris 30 rebonds
offensifs en quatre matches ça prouve
que c'était en face des joueurs qui
étaient moins bons crus mais aussi
qu'ils aient une suractivité au rebond
offensif c'est un prospect billets
clairement et j'attends de voir ce qu'il
va faire et ce qu'il va continuer à
badalone mois secure remote errigo et tu
sais quoi alors sur leur ligue junior à
valence moi ce que j'avais noté ces
chéquiers attitude dans le tout va il
avait eu s'embrouillait il était au 11e
vraiment il est par contre sûr le sur la
compet moi je vais vraiment même quand
il prend des couches de trouver super
cadrés et en termes de concentration
c'est cool qu'à son âge il est déjà été
capable de corriger ça il ya préparé par
plus beaucoup de fautes alors que c'est
un mec qui dissuade énormément il a pu
votants 4 mars à coude pour un intérieur
il ya beaucoup d'intérêts compris qu'ils
prennent beaucoup de fautes un stage là
et lui le fait qu'ils puissent rester
aux tensions terrain pas prendre de
photos franchement c'est ça qui m'a le
plus impressionné
oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait de 158 % aux
lancers francs sur la conquête c'est
révélateur de quelque chose ou pas du
tout c'est pas mal d'heures je pense
pour un intérieur à de 16 ans
c'est pas exceptionnel mais c'est pas
c'est pas mal hein entraîneront rappel
l'ipad pas beaucoup de matchs il dit
vous lui aussi qui sont assez faibles
sur 24 tentatives en quatre matches
je trouve que c'est pas exceptionnel en
termes de mécanique c'est par un
exceptionnel
c'est un peu et un peu de mouvements du
visage un peu comme ça mais
il taperait espagne à trois points des
faits qui les prennent ça m'intéresse
déjà
et sur l'euroligue sur l'olive noël et à
0 sur 4 aux lancers francs donc je vais
pas te dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut le
mettre sur un parquet nba puis qui peut
jouer il ya forcément des ya forcément
des trucs à travailler et ça ce soir
mais la gestuelle je trouve qu'elle est
pas bien si des graisses que ça bien
évidemment il ya des choses à travailler
mais vu les bras qu'il a vu la
croissance qu'il a eus je pense que
c'est normal il va avoir besoin de temps
pour s'approprier ses bras clément
alors je rappelle pour ceux qui viennent
d'arriver qu'on est bien sûr planer
draft on parle des u16 d'élus 16
européen
on va enchaîner avec toi alan tu va nous
présenter deux joueurs allemands parce
que deutsche equities
et bien cette écoute oui car on marque
on parle de quoi on parle des meilleurs
prospects billet européen de la
dégénération 2005 2006 et 2007 donc en
gros on parle de
deux mecs qui ont verra pas une bille
est tout de suite mais qui ont le profil
pour jouer le biais on va parler d'abord
je commence parti je ne sais pas par le
plus jeune quand même qu'on sépare
jamais
par declan tour où les clans douroux en
fait c'est moi je connaissais mois très
honnêtement je connaissais pas les
jantes les gens de cette génération
parce que j'ai on a souvent pas accès à
du film où ce gratuitement de qualité en
championnat ce que j'ai marqué un peu le
championnat domestique donc des
championnats des fenêtres jeunes en
espagnol par exemple ou allemand donc
moi je suis arrivé en fait avec je
connaissais quasiment personne hors
joueurs français que je connais parce
qu'on les connaît un peu tous parce que
nico j'en parle souvent et cuit qui peut
avoir en votre âme et les allemands par
exemple je connaissais cette personne
est en fait je suis arrivé le premier
jour avec nico avec d'autres scouts à
l'échauffement de l'équipe d'allemagne
avant le match contre la lettonie avant
le match contre la lettonie et en fait
on est de voir on est de voir chypre
hongrie avant
les progrès qu'ils étaient bas du basket
à c'était voilà il y avait des joueurs
qui joueront sûrement professionnels en
europe et en fait je suis arrivé et j'ai
vu les choses mon équipe demain l'équipe
d'allemagne ou en fait bas les mecs ont
commencé à mettre des 8000 en fait à 16
ans ç'a commencé à mettre des dingues de
partout et dans ce délire là il y avait
ni qu'on m'avait dit tu vas voir il ya
un gars qui a 14 ans et qui fait de m 2
des gens et c'est exane roues donc
declan d'ur où il joue au real madrid
comme égorger mines il est né en 2007
il fait 2 m 2 alors oui il faut le dire
les gens c'est un vrai 2007 il est ce
qu'il ya les certificats de naissance il
est né en europe donc il ya c'est un
vrai 2007 d'origine nigériane comme pas
mal de joueurs dans de cette génération
allemande de mai de mettre 2 14 ans et
j'arrive je le vois et il fait un 360 en
fait un échauffement avec d'une fluidité
hyper impressionnante
je me suis dit ok là c'est pas normal
c'est un mec super long extrêmement
longs
qui n'a pas de poste en fait j'écris un
scooter et pour ce qui va sortir dans la
semaine on a on s'était dit on va
attendre d'en faire une émission d'abord
pensé je peux pas définir de poste je
peux je peux pas définir de postes
offensifs pour lui pour l'instant je
peux définir et définir un rôle c'est
que c'est un finisseur d'action il sera
acquitté au mais alan est ce qu'on peut
dire à julien 51 d'arrêter d'écrire des
conneries par contre 12 bataille
roumanie est ce que tu as déjà vu de
rejouer c'est ridicule je n'ai pas de
taille roumanie c'est un joueur qui
était ultra dominant espoirs des stats
monstrueuse
2006 dis pas de bêtises oui et qui n'a
malheureusement pas percé qui a fini en
joueurs de nationale 3 on avait failli
signer au met d'ailleurs un petit
dédicace au met mais ça n'a strictement
rien à voir declan roussin 2007 donc on
va lui laisser du temps déjà
c'est un 2007 par instant un finisseur
d'action c'est à dire alors les petits
clips qui ont qui sont passées c'est pas
quelqu'un qui peut créer son tiercé
paquin qu'un haendel il peut pas faire
ça encore là il a 14 ans et vue qui fait
de m 2 à 14 ans il a toujours ultra
dominés physiquement donc il n'a jamais
eu besoin en fait quand dans les
catégories dans lesquelles il a joué de
développer attirant sortie dribble
quelque chose comme ça
il ya une ou deux actions oui mais des
dunks à son âge c'est vraiment pas
normal en fait il ya un dunk ou nico
était juste à côté de moi c'était contre
la bulgarie et je le rate je suis je
m'en veux encore je le rate pas ce que
je regarde autre chose à ce moment là je
crois qu'il a sauté sur deux joueurs il
y parle in de fond en fait il par ligne
de fond et il a il saute sur deux
joueurs il écrase le ballon à demain et
ensuite une autre fois contre un autre
joueur il va super y parle on line et il
fait un dunk à une main incroyable aussi
donc pour l'instant je peux pas définir
de poste je peux pas définir de position
et je peux définir un rôle un finisseur
d'action un mec qui finira pivot je
pense qu'ils défensivement s'il gagne un
petit peu en
explosivité grâce à sa longueur sa ses
mains de pieuvre pourra peut-être
dans un système en switch j'en suis pas
sûr encore mais il ya tout l'intérieur
moderne le tir n'est pas exceptionnel
mais il a 14 ans il a 14 ans qui disent
tout à fait correct pour gamins de son
âge dans cette compétition là ils tous
les 6 à 7 2 ans sur cas ce livre n'est
pas la victoire à 6,5 rebonds en 20
minutes sinon plus tous très correct
complètement et l'autre lui il a crevé
un peu les gens me gusta 'the way
complètement l'eau qui s'est passé juste
en face à l'estudiantes c'est martine
callot martin kalou bas lui c'est lui et
moi c'est tout ouais c'est le sosie de
leroy ça n'est en fait signé jean les
designers c'est le roi ça n'est en fait
il a le joueur du bayern munich il a
vraiment la même tête et de précision à
ses droits ce année c'est incroyable et
pareil j'arrive dans le jim et c'est le
système 8000 mais un 8000 incroyable de
facilité de fluidité c'est c à c ur la
question autour de martin kall où il a
tourné à 27 points et 8 rebonds sur la
compétition à 14 sur 28 à trois ponts ce
n'est pas je pense son vrai niveau aux
tirs c'est pas possible en fait tiré
rossi bien
il a fait des matches incroyables un 8
sur 10 notamment contre la bulgarie qui
vient un peu gonflé ses stades parce que
dans les autres matches il n'est pas
aussi bien ce match contre la bulgarie
en ligne était avec nikos et ses deux
meilleurs matchs mois que j'ai vu de
tout l'été en termes de prosper analyser
ce le publicité incroyable en termes
d'action il ya la salle était un peu
plein en plus parce que c'était en
bulgarie et la bulgarie jouer en termes
de restrictions comme ne s'était pas
tous respectés mais
c'est
ca c
c'était vraiment raison du
vide un peu car
on le respecte un témoin mais en tout
cas et la salle était peine c'était
vraiment top et kalou avait incroyable
incroyable il fini à 36 points à 8 sur
12 sur 21 8 sur 10 à
trois points il a loupé la date dix mois
excuse moi faut le conseiller à tout le
monde en fait faut regarder faut
regarder la première mi-temps de
d'allemagne mont garet parce
qu'effectivement je suis d'accord avec
toi moi j'en ai fait beaucoup c'était la
onzième ou la deuxième fois que j'allais
voir des tournois c'est la meilleure
huit ans que j'ai vu tout tout tout
confondu c'était vraiment ça rentrait
dedans à chaque fois et
pour de compléter sur kalou moi ce qui
m'a impressionné c'est que je me suis
dit sur un match c'est possible d'être
adroit mais il a l'air d'être athlétique
et tout je pense pas qu'il ait encore un
futur c'est peut-être juste une
exception qui tu regardes un deuxième
match et plantes puis un troisième match
y plante il a été incroyable après pour
moi petit bémol
physiquement
pour l'instant il domine parce qu'il est
prêt alors que les autres le sont pas
donc du coup avoir petit point
d'interrogation là dessus du coup je
reviens sur déclame deux roues
moi j'ai été super déçu par declan
d'euros même si c'est un 2007 je
m'attendais à autre chose qu'un grand
qui a du mal à à dribbler qui peut pas
pas qui peut pas dépasser battre les
appuis de quelqu'un en un contre un
défensivement pareil c'est pas encore
très solide c'est encore un 2007 et
julien j'insiste à la différence de
tahirou il a vraiment 14 ans declan
d'euros c'est ce qui fait que pour
l'instant on ne peut pas on peut pas
avoir de jugement on peut pas continuer
declan nourrigat terre ou sani et c'est
une grosse bêtise c'est pour ça que je
dis ça voilà après voilà je n'ai ce
rapport là franchement pour conclure
lacanau donc il va signer au bayern
munich
[Musique]
d'un club de deuxième division
c'est ça
les change pas
très loin de brême 82 chez julien qu'on
embrasse d'outils exactement dont il va
rejoindre le bayern munich
je pense que ça c'est très c'est bien
paul et c'est intéressant pour lui et
oui ça va falloir le voir dans les
prochains allait prochainement des
prochains mois le projet d'y aller pour
voir si c'était ce que je m'impose
heures dans le produit dans le scrutin
et porter ce que on est sur un simple
coup de chaud d'une semaine aux tirs et
en couleurs où est ce que il va
développer le reste ça parce que
pensants comme l'a dit nico c'est une
grosse menace transition mais sur
attaque placée il ya encore pas mal de
défauts voilà mais
le aller voir si vous avez le temps bien
sûr du temps à tuer d'une allemagne
bulgarie 16 il est vraiment vraiment
exceptionnel de niveau de jeu et puis
marking kalou voir le roi sané péter des
énormes thomas c'est vraiment cool et
pilotis meneur bulgare gave you love
aleksandar google i o phone voilà c'est
c'est juste exceptionnel s'est remis la
vidéo lamy le cross du tour dans le
cross le plus beau cross où j'ai vu de
ma vie en en réel il a fait marcher
déclame de route sur 5 m il est trahi
mais encore ilan est tombé et repris
mais le tir
et on peut être qu'on peut on a le temps
de répondre à la question de paul 20 12
bayard ouais on a le temps on y va
comment comment faites vous pour juger
d'une progression d'un procès entre les
15 16 ans et 18 20 ans bah en fait ça se
passe ça tombe bien c'est un peu la
question dans lequel j'avais posé et
aussi ce qu'on regarde spécifiquement au
niveau dans cette catégorie d'âge
alors dans les deux catégories la
progression on regarde d'abord la
progression physique savoir s'il a
grandi si s'épaississent y voit là il
donne des signes de maturité physique et
qu'on puisse un peu le placer il ya une
située au cap sur internet et celle de
maturité tu vas tomber sur des études
très anciennes qui ont été faites par
des des scientifiques américains qui te
donne un peu les différentes échelles de
la maturité du coup tu peux mettre ce
stade un stade 2 sets à 3 quand tu as de
la pilosité
des choses comme ça en sachant petit
astérisque que pour les grecs et les
turcs par exemple la pilosité elle
différente que pour un allemand ou un
norvégien donc du coup il faut prendre
ça aussi en ligne de compte après sur la
progression technique ce que tu attends
d'un joueur de 15 16 ans on regarde à la
demie amis declan deux roues dans les
prospects billet je les nie aussi en
sachant qu'il a été nul sur le terrain
grossièrement si je veux vraiment je
grossis le trait pourquoi parce qu'en
fait on on regarde ce qu'il va être
capable de faire les promesses on
regarde on regarde pas ce qu'il est
capable de faire techniquement ce dinan
bon il peut pas faire ça c'est terminé
et du coup cette progression là bas tu
vois declan drew l'an prochain ou dans
deux ans qu'on va regarder à la noix et
les autres c est ce qu'il est capable de
changer de direction en dribblant déjà
premier aspect est deuxième après le tir
la gestuelle
comment ils bougent en défense
aujourd'hui il a envie de défendre sur
des arrières mais il en est pas capable
c'est trop lourd le cross qui cependant
contre le menu un bulgare et l image
parfaite ça faisait deux trois actions
que ont parlé à la demande et il va s'en
prendre à elle va s'en prendre à parce
que il essayait
absolument de défendre sur des petits
pour prouver aux scouts présent qu'il
était capable de le faire mais pour
l'instant il peut pas le faire et comme
le dit alan je pense qu'il finira pivot
donc à voir comment ils comment il va
bosser le jeu de jean mais c'est assez
lourd
très bien messieurs ça fait du meilleur
que ses plages d'afrique a commencé on
va parler de deux prospects européens
que ce soit en river art et nicolas
jovic pour ça on va parler anglais avec
notre habité l'open bar
live
night
so
i see you have vidéo un bruit bizarre il
sera au
mieux totalement au
bois du 6
mai
l'express
[Musique]
je lui ai posé par attrition rapidement
je lui ai posé la question de savoir ce
qu'il
s'est vu qu'ils avaient fait une vidéo
donc soit on révise arles l'intérieur
estonien ce qu'il en pensait il a dit
qu'il l'aimé beaucoup et que pour lui
comme le dit la formule consacrée ce sky
is the limit et qu' il voyait pas
beaucoup de gros défauts alan
nico c'est toi qui l'a beaucoup aimé je
crois
yes
je commence en anglais en français et en
anglais
raphaële hiault view
un wanna dance to sing weaver et à
madrid une ligue mineure et wasabi soft
10h à filtrer les postes techniques aux
is becoming tough
nhc il commande vocale
et baby
[Musique]
it's good for him because asus est de
technicals qu'ils order and money aussi
de
sybase inc
du à griffer comprime tous les
goûts
donc je demande je demandais à raphaël
en gros je vous disais que ce qu'il a vu
cet été par rapport à la dureté c'était
nouveau et que ça c'est top parce qu'il
est en train de devenir un homme
physiquement et même il est plus vocal
il il prend plus de place dans la
raquette et après je faisais une
mauvaise comparaison ce qui est ma
spécialité et donc du coup je le disais
est ce que d'accord avec moi si si tu
veux qu'on parle de la horie mark allen
et il me disait alors le marché n'était
plus un spécialiste un peu plus à l'aise
pour
pour le tir est par contre il y avait
aussi cette question de la de la dureté
est ce que j'ai oublié d'être sûrement
dit ginette halal
[Musique]
pour
nico
[Musique]
j'en fais justement d'arafat qu'est-ce
que blizzard devait travail enfin nous
passe quand vous le dire il est donc
c'est un simple 2004 3 ou 2003 je sais
plus donc ça aurait il une très bonne
can enjoy the new
world
series deuxième d'énergie nazran manière
mans par exemple saut et il me disait
qui pourrit pour qu'il gagne en maturité
physique surtout sur le haut du corps
qu'il soit plus fort la pièce et je
rajoute un mot la nba en termes de
l'intérieur s'est on se rend pas compte
des phénomènes physiques en fait donc
pour le moment ça peut être un peu
compliqué là dessus mais ça qu'il a
gagné un petit peu un peu puissant
en dureté en dureté cet été et c'est
assez chaud dit qu'il fallait voter
en ligne
sps
on y
est
little [ __ ] up soit une offre
technique
et
fred offre
lui demander s'il n'y avait pas une
question sur le physique qui les
capacités athlétiques au river ça
il est donc une disait que grosso modo
aussi y avait toujours cette intensité
qui a été mise et que même si ce n'était
pas exceptionnel ce point de vue là et
que toute façon il est encore jeune et
qu'il faut aussi développer justement en
se musclant et en épaississant son corps
ça pouvait vraiment le faire avec eux le
talent ils sont belles à voir mais tout
un conte lui fallait mieux se concentrer
au prix mais sur des choses très basket
comme multi air extérieur par exemple
parce que c'est un peu ce qui ce qui
n'est bon ni qu une autre question
on en est donc à vie
franchement je ne sais pas j'ai pas
vraiment d'autres questions sur sur les
armes la question que je me posais
c'était par rapport à la tâche mais
c'est et c'est la première chose dont on
a parlé sceau made by raphael
you
will protect
project
inc
donc ma question c'est est-ce qui le
projette un nom pas ou est ce qui le
protège
et donc il nous a répondu qu'il avait le
talent pour être un premier tour que la
question était de savoir ce qu'ils
voulaient avait fini en college avant
d'être drafté aussi rester au real parce
que le problème avec l'équipe du real
c'est qu'elle est là où dit d'aller
plein de plein de talent de prospects
biais après il expliquait que ce qu'il a
fait cet été prêché pour lui et que du
coup ça allait lui donner un petit peu
de poids là dessus et qu'encore une fois
vraiment il avait le talent pour être un
premier tour et qu'il fallait voir
comment comment ça allait se développer
about de real madrid politique iny
estime
human rights in common foden to get like
the best and players possible
de brest will go round like the day
before so it's kind of
toutou d'innover
et donc là je j'expliquais je revenais
sur le real madrid sur le fait qu' ils
ont l'habitude c'est comme ça qu'il y eu
leur politique de jeunes serpents des
dix meilleurs joueurs possibles de m on
va dire tous les crocodiles dans la même
pièce et puis le meilleur single games
le real madrid
il expliqué raphaël que c'était vrai
aussi
cashman nuit
c'est comme on sait que c'est exactement
boys et ils se font vraiment pas mal
d'argent là-dessus et qui est en plus
ils forment des bons joueurs donc il
aurait tort de s'en priver
justin bizarre il ya de deux
attaques
et dit john dryden
bio et ngiti
istanbul hacking l'idéal sera vukcevic
ou
plutôt de france team nikon haut à
hermée bit indique des faits et social
ian read et brad spence soucis vis de la
vie des élèves de cannes toulouse et
gordini nass wind est un
petit peu la liste de tous les joueurs
qu'ils avaient fait sinon il ya la fiche
du real madrid sur le site envergure et
que tous les
messieurs ce que j'ai des choses à
rajouter sur brive et zares le prospect
estonie vous qu'on attend la draft 2023
dites-moi d'accord oui exactement six
livres a tout de suite
ok eh ben on va passer tout de suite que
je rappelle on est toujours sur payet
draft on a parlé des 8 16 avant là on
parle des dons qu'on parlait de rory
bizarre le prospect estoniens et là on
va partir sur du gros gros gros
prospects européen avec nicolas beach
soccer
nikolaïevitch jeff who the best job et
nos
prospects
trois titres nba soit aux lecteurs
avec
nina
et
donc en fait je posais la question
savoir si nicolas jovic donc l'ailier
serbe
merveilleux qu'on a pu voir cet été
était pour lui le meilleur producteur
européen alors produit divx et de la
question était en fait assez compliqué
parce qu'il y avait aussi un zodiac de
prétendre à être dans ce spot là après
il est ce qu'ils disaient c'est que par
rapport à lui en tant qu'américains il
trouve que les prospères européen c'est
une autre façon d'aborder le jeu et met
que quelques fois lui il avait tendance
à forcer un petit peu et ce qui lui
faisait alors appeler un jeune des
jeunes t2
donc voila mais tu es un voire deux de
grands talents
à la ddt toi tu je crois que tu as assez
fan du joueur ce contient des remarques
des questions
so what you
did you and i want you by night in audio
vidéo live de tunis watching you take
that méga
pas
réussi
at the night in night in any
way
niveau 5a de haine dit-il hajiti in
raising nicolas crousse
ans que je demande à apple en gros ce
qui a eu la chance de le voir dans
plusieurs contextes cette source qui est
plus intéressant entre donc le fil
laconique 19 en lettonie la serbie fait
demi-finale
et les anglais dans le meilleur cinq de
la compet il est vraiment très très bon
et aussi le voir avec mes gars qui va
mais galex méga b-max legacy corbett
change tout le temps mais est donc voila
c il ne voir dans différents contextes
c'est intéressant il a toujours été très
très bon rallye ou l'autre des contacts
en fait je disais ça tu veux je peux
poser une autre question j'en ai une
main compris
appel au newcastle by des attitudes de
body language
[Rires]
[Musique]
le maire
donc je demandais d'un bar loup à
monsieur barlow que comment il
voyait ce qu'il était inquiet de
l'attitude de beach
avec ses coéquipiers
le body language et il m'a répondu en
disant pas déjà je suis américain vu que
ça ne s'achète pas je suis habitué et
ensuite ce qu'il apprécie chez lui pour
faire court c'est sa capacité à tenir
compte de ses coéquipiers il est pas
seulement le méchant comme on peut le
parlé du cadeau cicchelli ces derniers
temps et qu'en plus il est très
compétiteur du coup forcément c'est
quelque chose de positif
cannes by night
and day camerini chattering nba 2k
games in the
nose
peur
10h04
et
qu'ils ont une
offre
il a très bien
marché du tea party
puis je vous demander s'ils pensaient
que jobbik pourrait atteindre 17 heures
principaux la nba moi je vois plutôt
comme un deuxième initiateurs il dit que
non et le vois plus comme une web d'une
arme en fait à côté d'un premier
incident d'un animateur principal quand
même prendre des décisions balle en main
ensuite j'ai vu qu'il avait dit que
c'était tu avais posé la question
entraîne sosa et hewitt pour le meurtre
aux pays venant d'europe j'aimerais
c'est ce qui est ce qu'il préférait une
sauce à rejoindre la franchise par
rapport à part catherine quéré vous
au cibona cette année un bon début d'une
bonne fin de saison un bon début de
saison là avec lui il a dit que voici un
c'est encore un débat de scott
vaccination le meilleur joueur
aujourd'hui à l'instant t mais c'est pas
ce qu'on recherche en raflant un jour de
ces âges like est essentielle mais que
je pense que peut-être c'est pas le
meilleur contexte pour lui à une sauce à
à malaga fois que c'est malaga nikon 1 à
malaga et le contexte collectif qui peut
peut-être le faire chuter dans pas mal
de bord
on a une question de julien qui nous dit
quel poste en nba jovic
rafale au
wat which position folio vie de famille
ici maso for in nba note africa
to
make any différence de fribourg
mais
[Musique]
julien moi j'ai expliqué avant dix ans
que moi je le vois plus comme un 4 que
comme 1 3 parce que pour moi il aura pas
là dit il fera pas la différence balle
en main face à 1,3 alors que en 4 comme
l'expliquait raphaël il va pouvoir
profiter des miss match il va pouvoir
attaquer des joueurs qui seront
peut-être
- habitué à avoir quelqu'un de son
profil sur le poste 4 g j'ai perdu plein
de trucs dans la traduction alan parce
que j'étais en train de lire autre chose
et non pas à compléter si j'ai oublié
des choses importantes dix équipes
rappelle commencé comme 1,4 s'il ya un
switch ya des ajustements défensifs
avoir un rôle différent et que l on
parle d'un mec qu'est né en 2003 donc
tout ce qui évoque sa position c'est
assez délicat déjà qu'en nba pour moi
aujourd'hui les positions ça veut dire
les rôles c'est tous des rôles sont
relancés mais sûrement porter de barrage
ou contre des bots ce qu'on dit mais tu
as raison deuxième porteur de balle
même temps excès de 0,8
pour poser
nos
positions
at
il donc no 2 et no love each raphaël l
is asking if you can't be compared to
mamou quel âge il
a innové
[Rires]
[Musique]
il disait que non il
il pense pas que jovic soit dans le même
profil que même qu'elle à julie déjà par
rapport au body talk au type de corps
mais aussi par rapport à ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire sur le terrain est ce
que j'ai oublié quelque chose
non après qu'il ait mais quand même bien
même
il est drafté il faut le dire pour milou
et
les gars qui enchaîne
[Musique]
les
esprits
[Musique]
bon
et régionaux gutkès qu'il aimait
regarder danger dans les matchs de
jeunes au point qu est-ce qui a apprécié
et il a répondu c'est un petit peu un
cliché mais c'est la vérité que c'est
pas pareil que des matchs et ue et ybm
aux etats unis c c ou c beaucoup plus de
capacités athlétiques et des
individuels qui va gagner là en europe
via un poisson que c'est ça le jour un
peu plus bas c'est peut-être plus
cérébrale s'est il ya là dessous de
représenter son pays qui est importante
aussi et qui sait c'est pas du tout la
même chose et qu'il a il apprécie
vraiment regarder
on va remercier raphaël on va on est
très bien dans les temps dans le timing
et 21h ça fait une heure qu'on est là à
parler de prospects u 16 u 18 19
et on va bientôt attaquer le débat nous
habite et sont dans les starting blocks
pour faire 5 you so much for coming
up
alors donc du coup on remerciera r
raphaël rapidement il disait qu'il
allait sûrement passer bientôt
par la france donc en novembre ou verra
pas de tir
aura passé maintenant au débat c'est
l'heure du débat sur les stages et on va
accueillir olivier et antoine tout de
suite
messieurs jean cras
mais c'est un vase et
pour moi c'est bonjour mais bon ça chez
vous
donc je vais vous laisser vous présenter
pour ceux qui vous connaissent pas allez
y messieurs
allez au
caire par ordre alphabétique alors je
préfère vraiment charest je suis pigiste
à new york principalement sur le sport
est sûre la nba depuis quelques années
maintenant et en ce moment les
collaborations principal son équipe
canal+ pasquette info
ça marche et là tu sors du média d de
délaisser des brooklyn nets c'est un
petit peu la course des gens qui ont pas
répondu dans le week-end répondre
maintenant donc ça a été une journée un
peu folle là je bonjour moi je vous
offre un cadre sympa mais je suis pas
chez moi je suis à grandes centrales
voilà tourner la caméra sur le stream
mais voilà voilà super olivier
donc olivier
jean français jean illuminé et qui bat
je représente une quarantaine joueurs de
coke en france et à l'international et
j'ai réalisé les draps cas notamment de
gershon l'homme cedh et en 2016 les
besoins de 6 et en 2010 celle de franck
et qu'il a avec les new york
et enfin un accueil romain qui nous a
rejoint salut romain bonsoir tout le
monde
donc bon soir romain qu'on présente plus
les sports pour la draft assistant coach
de la sig strasbourg
avec notamment un joueur dont on a parlé
la dernière de wonderbox était notre
amitié de sd est sûre on suivra tout
particulièrement
donc messieurs je vous ai réunis pour
parler d'un sujet à propos des drafts
tâche parce qu on a quand même
l'impression que cette affaire-là ça
marche pas trop trop bien donc j'aimerai
avoir vos avis et qu'on trouve un petit
peu de tout ça peut venir le fait que ce
soit pas la voie royale pour accéder à
la nba on voit notamment avec
zahia cordier cac a du mal à trouver un
spot on peut se poser aussi la question
par rapport à juin de bégard un qui
vient de se faire drafté et a renvoyé à
paris par boston est ce que
pour vous d'où vient le problème
je suis moi si on te gèles rampe et j'ai
répondu bêtises tout le monde se marre
c'est pas pour ta question c'est celle
là oui je sais
les efforts qui ont été faits sur le
décor là antoine à une phénoménale sur
une coupole nicolas des poutres médias
c'est absolument parfait on revient au
sujet je suis désolé
peut-être qu'on va commencer avec
olivier qui nous rappelle un peu
peut-être qu'ils nous disent tout
simplement les polices mais comment ça
se passe un draft un stage comme ce que
ça se décide pas ce que c'est de façon
unilatérale et que ça se négocie tout ça
nous on sait pas trop au niveau du
conflit
en parallèle pratiquement pour la voir
qu
on va dire que quelques quelques mois
imposée
gershon pour faire mieux la
rétrospective été un jour qu'ils étaient
plutôt tendues sur un deuxième tour pour
tout le process couloir mais autres
tables et pertinemment qu'il avait les
standards fils bill christie est pas
tout est
vraiment intéressante pour aller entre
guillemets les esprits sur un parcours
de ouaga travers les différentes îles
donc c'est un garçon qui a vu sa cote
monte basse ont créé des attentes sur
les trois cavalières semaines avant la
draft au point d'arrivée clairement sur
des projets ou qu'il faisait rentrer
dans la loterie
donc à partir du moment où vous aurez
sur le premier tour les discussions
commencent à se mettre en place ou des
franchises demande au préalable à ces
représentants calella quelle est la
volonté du joueur si des cas s'il ya dix
huit ans et levier est ce qu'il est
contre justement système de rappel page
et aiderait le plan qu on proposerait en
cas de drame stage dans lequel garonne
ne sauvegarde pas mal de francis du
premier tour au milieu du premier mois
jusqu'à la fin du co maîtrise était
vraiment vraiment très liées à ce sujet
qui avait montré un intérêt réel savoir
qu'il avait réalisé 3 l de work à droite
m qui est énorme et il est vraiment
marqué les esprits et on avait loué nu
un secret de polichinelle il y avait un
très fort intérêt des clippers à
l'époque le concernant qui a chois
numéro 24 est si clairement avec l'âge
dans leur faire séculaire arrive le soir
de races et les équipes concrètement
contactez nous pour savoir encore une
fois quelques jours nos intentions et
pour répondre de façon très claire
impression au moment où deux hommes
décident
de passer at il pas là zèle ils ont qu'a
demandé quel était notre fille ses
ventes us qu'elle tiendra sa part que
dans le cadre de la halle et très grande
majorité des lois pas dire 90 % des
jouets il n'y a pas grand-chose à
imposer sur une draft hormis lorsque
vous êtes un candidat donne des
garanties légitimes et bien fixé au
préalable le soir de la draft voilà un
refus de leur avantage ça peut être
utile à cannes on entend une horde nous
conte cap mais j'ai fait le kit avait
d'emblée insisté sur le fait de khadra
sur le 16e choix qui était imputée aux
d'emblée marqué sur l'hypothèse d'un
tâche en europe ou en asie donc c'est
quelque chose qu'ils avaient participé
c'est à dire qu'il n'avait pas de place
dans le roster moment où ils grattent et
garonne pas de place dans leurs pertes à
ce poste-là donc pas quelque chose qui
est relativement 6
ensuite après effectivement un travail
de collaboration avec francis on va
peut-être trouvé recadre qui convienne
un peu à tout le monde aussi aux joueurs
qu'à la france yves poursuivre on met en
place le midi pour mettre en place un
accompagnement cliniques techniques etc
on pourra reparler à vue du foie qui a
condamné avec l'effectif des guerres
seul de rejoindre ma fille voilà pour
répondre à la question effectivement
quelque chose qui avait suivi et et qui
a été fait en amont du choix de la draft
assure que la décision est acceptée aux
prises par le guaje entourage un autre
que l'on est dans un choix donc t'as
qu'à six nations qui n'ont pas la place
ben waters pour rappeler qu'il
faut se dire aussi que c'est vrai que
c'était un choix aux un gâchis en 1
16ème de l'envoyer à brassens tâche mais
en fait c'est pas
moi j'avais vu un truc en préparant un
petit peu que c'est ce qu'a 2018 en fait
il y avait jamais eu de draft où il n'y
a pas un joueur du top 40 donc quasiment
du premier tour c'est vrai ça s'arrête à
30 qui n'a pas été envoyé en raft en
stage donc en fait c'est très très très
très commun quelque part par contre j'ai
là je pense qu'olivier tu peux nous en
parler un petit peu
tous les drafts en stage ce ne sont pas
les mêmes quoi dans le sens où qu'elle
est l'accompagnement qu'ils aient mis
derrière parce que c'est pareil est ce
qu'un jour a été pris parce que vraiment
la franchise le veut mais qu'elle a un
doute est-ce qu'elle l'enlève à une
autre équipe qui a l'air un peu plus
convaincu ce qu'on sait qu'à être ça
aussi qu'est ce qui est
plus à demain la plus importante qu'est
ce qui fait un bond raft ndash mais
quelque part et antoine avant à vendre
les oliviers répondre et avant de vous
quitter
ça serait bien qu'on explique ce qu'est
un draft en stage
ouais là que j'étais clairement juste
aux collégiens ont par contre avec
l'intervention de l'idc tu draf le
joueur stage ça veut dire que tu le mets
un petit peu sur l'étagère en gros sur
l'étagère c'est comme l'expliqué olivier
quoi la chine l'europe l'australie c'est
bien de plus en plus commun pour faire
développer le joueur ailleurs quelque
part en attendant de le ramener en nba
et éventuellement il faut regarder les
pourcentages et pas pu les préparer
aussi je suis pas quelqu'un l'a fait
qu'est ce que ça donne derrière vraiment
parce qu'en fait la beaucoup tous les
ans et pas tous accès de l'ennemi
effectivement
sur ce mois je vais faire un draft n
splash jeu
je vous souhaite à tous une bonne soirée
et ollier ça fait plaisir de voir des
courts et antoine bon courage à
grande-synthe côté famille
qui est bien grande centrale que je
collais l'heure connus ouais c'est bien
sachez entre un truc à un autre donc ça
tombe bien elle est donc olivier on
avait parlé
le choix du club après comment ça se
décide ça aussi c'est comment la corse
et unilatérale ça vient d'où s'est
négocié ou pas le choix de justement
pour gershon à l'époque de rejoindre la
chine en venant donc du championnat de
france
pouvait un petit peut surprendre aussi
quel était l'intérêt pour lui
l époque en fait dans le calgary sun qui
a fait particulier parce que d'anglais
et celtic doit réfléchir à une solution
qui permettra de transition la plus
sacrée les plus souples par rapport aux
divers élus liés alors pourquoi chine
premièrement c'est plein tenté de
franchir en chine d'avoir chez les
chants des attaques à l'époque c'est la
france qui est présidée par yao ming qui
derrière siliana
bien ne prononça de la liste sûrs si
l'opep a ouvert la boîte sera mais je
suis fier d'être avec des vrais manques
aliments mensuel par rapport à son
évolution physique parlera pas des
curseurs qui ont été faits sur le poêle
et cosy dit et la gestion c'est depuis
et c'est donc 4 vraiment entre
guillemets un quart de travail par
rapport à shanghai ils ont des relations
de très bonne qualité avec domingo
forcément il ya déjà des choses il ya c
est facile en terme de de futilité des
os et ensuite après on est sur un
championnat qui est relativement court
qui pour les équipes qui ne croit les
flammes s'arrêtent quasiment des dumas
et je sais pas si vous en avez qui a
permis à grächen arrêté son championnat
avec lâcher et de tout de suite basculer
en vie il a terminé l'année en ville qui
pour laisser fixer entre guillemets les
façons de quoi accélérer son adaptation
par oral unitaire et levier et ont eu
les mêmes livres américains donc le swag
la chine destitution premièrement une
passe travail avec avec naomi watts
deuxièmement avec une compatibilité des
quadrilles et parce que si vous partez
une saison européenne est une équipe qui
a une coupe homme qui peut aller jusqu'à
70 et que vous arrivez quasiment mi juin
le joueur et les r1 est fatigué même
sens à leur ligue il avait toutes les
chances d'avoir loire qui arrive
finalement sur les rotules donc voila
voila un petit peu là à la génèse de but
soit de shanghai après fait quelque
chose son stage c'est quand même vrai
menée en collaboration il n'ya rien
exposé de toute façon à certains moments
houleux le
la franchise drafté au premier tour elle
et elle est redevable d'un contrat
garanti aucun moment quand même que ça
se passe correctement que le joueur axel
face au final parce que c'est un accord
verbal un accord verbal est trouvé avec
la france il avant le plat la drave n'y
a rien de contractuel donc forcément il
faut quand même qu'ils il devrait une
vraie coloration là dessus effectivement
c'est quelque chose et qui est discuté
qui est bien en place nous rejoindre un
petit peu d'étudier pierre mois jusque
là l'a souligné jusqu'en 2008 le drapé
le stage quelque chose qui était très
commun mais qui à mon sens était surtout
une manière pour les sites n'avaient pas
de place dans leur rsa qui n'avaient pas
de matariya
bible de papier le rejoindra de draft un
mec sur lequel se dit des bois on verra
dans deux rampes et elle qui réalise un
frein un potentiel de venir jouer en
summer league tous les étés et
finalement qui ne nous oblige à
absolument du contraintes financières
mais quelque part n'est même pas mis
notre libero couveuse bras j'ai appelé
ça vraiment mis en standby quoi semapa
en couveuse sur la commode à l'effet
qu'il quand même de une un critère de
développement vous êtes en couveuse vous
mettez des moulins croyez aux joueurs
vous mettez un staff à disposition là il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'art qui
était clairement stendhal et je crois
finit pas de vide que le dernier exemple
de drague tâche qui a fonctionné c'est
bogdanovic qui a été drafté en 2014 et
en 2015 voire qui l'aidera t il à 14
points de moyenne on dit donc il peut
permettre de dire moi je veux encore ni
en euroligue et dans sa foulée qu'il ya
d'autres paysages au fenerbahçe istanbul
euroligue et il fait trois top niveau
européen donc lui pour lui les licences
d'accord est relié par ailier jeunesse
il était supposé peut faire des pubs
pour aider sur le graal européen at il
eu à travailler mais hormis ce cet
exemple là je ne sais pas si vous vous
en avez j'ai pas a récemment
que
sur les françaises c'est pas récent mais
en fait celui qui a bien marché c'est
celui de yann mamie quoi mais bon c'est
laisser les spurs sa remontée voilà et
c'est l'espace et c'est pour ça que je
disais que tu m appelles ça je ne sont
pas les mêmes c'est que yann leur
raconter quand lui via son draft-n
stages déjà
après la draft ils font venir donc tu la
direction quasiment
il joue avant tout
rester des ils font venir la direction
le coach
beaucoup de choses ensuite il a envoyé
lui faut un vrai programme de
développement l'année d'après il va à
pau pour faire de l'euroligue et quand
ils arrivent même si là encore
de là à l'époque gillick la g-league
c'était la d-league
il ya encore derrière un vrai programme
etc c'est vraiment toutes les étapes
sont prévues en fait c'est pas ce côté
vraiment ce terme d'eustache c'est
vraiment ce côté mettre un peu sur
l'étagère quoi c est ce que vraiment on
ira le chercher plus tard la santé qui
avec un petit peu un programme derrière
et moi je me demande si fâcheux
maintenant je pense que la question ne
doit vraiment être mise sur la table est
ce que il n'ya pas des stages qui
franchement de tours de draft est pris
mais qu'est ce qui vraiment se passe
derrière quoi
dans l'histoire dans l'histoire dans les
vingt dernières années il ya l'exemple
de boy tanovic pour moi plus encore en
terme de réussite il ya l'exemple de
jean aux biches et plus anciens mais
ginobili la raf 199 s'il arrive à ce
londonien en 2002 2003 en sachant qu'à
l'époque c'est déjà un joueur de top
standing mais c'est pour moi une des
plus grandes réussites de draft ou si tu
fais le rapport au niveau auquel été
drafté la carrière qu'il a derrière en
cinquante septième choix c'est fabuleux
mais encore une fois c'est les spurs à
une époque est différente
il a deux fois les peurs
les profils dentelle projections étaient
capables à comprendre le modèle européen
avec la marge de progression est apeuré
avec la caf et de collaboration avec les
routes européennes y a pas énormément
consiste en une bille qui ont trait aux
réseaux en europe de collaboration et de
plus dit échanges et les lieux dont on
reparlera mais lui et puis l'eau billy
finalement 6 et merci encore une fois
le bouton mi-août je le fais une fois
injectées pour être la plus ancienne
c'est bon de les fêtes
quelqu'un nous demandent à 6,6 au kitsch
et ai été été embarquée moustache
yukichi et des raretés en 2014 et il
arriva il arrive à denver en 2015-2016
donc il a passé une année une année
encore visiblement un méga l'ex fils
drafté en continu 46e choix donc au
deuxième tour en 2014 donc c'est un
exemple également de
2,2 process qui réussit mais là encore
une fois d'éleveurs avec un modèle qui
est quand même va dire avec une vraie
connaissance du fonctionnement européen
et un accompagnement intéressant parce
que le maillage coup c'est la
connaissance de danger et pour moi c'est
très lent dans la franchise
quand même un peu un petit bémol là
dessus joffrey lauvergne arrive en même
temps
que l'auvergne le nord qui sont en même
temps et je ferai dit après deux trois
mois mais en fait légal n'avait pas
prévu que les otages soient aussi soir
même avec un tracé en stage suivi machin
de quand ils arrivent ils sont quand
même surpris du niveau donc à quel point
ils ont une visibilité sur le
développement du joueur quand il est en
stage ça pose des questions non mais
c'est c'est toujours pareil j'en ai déjà
parlé je suis en vie rigole quelques
années la drave de ginobili le scout des
sports de l'époque me raconte sur une
formation qui barre qu'elle se joue à
pile ou face
donc le choix à l'issue d'un choix entre
deux mails qui joue à pile ou face parce
qu il est 3h du matin qui reprend le tri
dans tous les sens et qu'il n'arrive pas
après le mec le dissez que ces
romanciers ou pas à lui été moi non mais
bon ça joue parfois sur un coupé donc
voilà là pour le coup est effectivement
si le métier surperforme je peux pas
savoir
mais mes tâches en plus qu'il ya un dieu
il ya eu des pommes différentes
super la 2015 2016 on est exclusivement
sur des tâches en europe aujourd'hui
chaque équipe est liée à safran chili
donc une équipe carrément vie développé
un joueur quel drame même qu'elle la
place suite pour lui elle a quand même à
32 jeudi elle a lieu tous les ans
donc il y à un moment je sache
aujourd'hui très différent il ya
beaucoup de joie et finalement son bras
deuxième tour qui sont tout de suite en
moyens j'ai dit c'est vous qui tout de
suite entre guillemets mis sur des tons
gantoise est pas vraiment un avant et un
après aux candidats feront
aussi le fait que la g-league maintenant
les joueurs quand même pas le même
niveau de salaire qu'avant
ça joue mais aucune vraie volonté des
français qui à mon avis que dix c'est
beaucoup plus facile de développer un
procédé qui à deux heures de voiture de
nous et qui peut freiner avec nous
régulièrement qui peut être pas un
déplacement convoi est quelque part
qu'on entraîne tu trouves que quelqu'un
prêt à
5 heures d'avion teaser d'avion et
avions dans une franchise dans une
équipe par donc dont on ne connaît pas
bien conscients qu'ils jouent deux fois
par semaine et cetera et cetera je pense
que l'algérie aujourd'hui d'un outil
développement pour eux est bien bien
bien
où il ya une perte
pour l'expliquer c'est vrai que
généralement pareil ceux qui le font
bien parce qu'il ya toujours ceux qui
sont bien ceux qui sont mal quand quand
il ya une équipe g-league normalement le
staff de la geely est une extension du
staff nba c'est un assistant coach qui
connaît très bien la culture du banc
actuelle en nba à devenir le head coach
andy dick par exemple on a plusieurs
exemples honnête raptor et c'est donc
effectivement c'est censé être
quasiment pas tout à fait non plus mais
comme est déjà un petit peu dans la
franchise
voilà une bielle avait pas de ligues
mineures en fait pendant longtemps donc
autrement et demi comme vous avez aimé
les lieux les six billets qu'ils
allaient thomas un petit peu qu'ils
publient par terre mais non
effectivement il n'y a pas ce principe
de ligues mineures mais
la mlb
le
principe des équipes mineures qui la
permet aussi d'aller chercher le joueur
avant la fac et pour cinq jours au bac
ne plus développer ces cinq six niveaux
différents donc c'est énorme c'est non
faire toujours comme double haut niveau
mais avoir chez soi d'ailleurs même si
tu ta confiance que tu parles avec les
stars parce que dans tous les cas c'est
a draftés un joueur tu après avec le
staff dans lequel il était
avant tu as parlé avec des quotas par
exemple ils connaissent quand même
préfère la voir dans ton dans ta salle
danton dont on écosystèmes je pense pour
se développer donc c'est pour ça que ça
va ça change vraiment mal un mec comme
ça ma nietzsche aux spurs pour moi avant
il aurait été en europe il devrait
testage en or là il est gay spurs depuis
un an un an et demi c'est une nouveauté
aussi
les structures et vu les moyens qui sont
mis à dispo dès des joueurs pour le
développement aux états unis enfin je
comprends je comprends pas que dans la
démarche un joueur puisse se dire je
préfère je préfère tenter les coups vont
de gimmicks de que dresse en europe je
dis pas que le niveau est meilleur ou
moins bon je sais qu'il ya des collègues
des collègues de deux jeeps et litres
par betclic élite faire taper sur les
doigts qui qui ont tendance un petit peu
à dénigrer le niveau le niveau de la
g-league niveau la dgid il est ce qu'il
est ce un championnat très particulier
qui là pour préparer les gens à gagner
au loto pain est tout simplement c'est à
dire acceleo à la marche dessus
directement mais les enjeux sont tels
d'un côté mais les structures sont elles
de l'autre je comprends les gens en
cercueil on jouerait le titre ça je n'ai
par contre dax aux 100 mentalement vont
pas régulièrement avec avec qui a
disparu ou qui a passé une saison à une
saison à ok si sur leur sur l'équipe de
geely et à s'entraîner avec un peu à
être avec les teams que l'équipe ait
lieu mais tonique clairement oui on se
déplace son but we sur sa un truc c'est
sûrement moins bien structuré ou
peut-être moins excitant de jouer en
ordre dans les salles pleines mais par
contre tu tu touches le dernier c'est à
dire que c est quand même très très
proche de ce qui se fait de mieux et et
on sache que je peux comprendre la
démarche
après chacun chacun dans sa carrière
comme il veut et chacun organise comme
il veut c'est pas moi jen et de
comprendre le truc sachant qu'en plus
aujourd'hui comme tu le faisais alors
que c'était pour antoine le niveau de
rémunération était quand même
beaucoup moins intéressant et
quelques-uns dit que maintenant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on peut quand
même réussir à dire à vivoter un an ou
deux ans jimmy choo on veut tenter
troupes pour aller voir plus haut donc
ce n'est pas non plus c'est pas une
intéressante cet aspect là aussi sur cet
aspect là aussi quand
on vous rappelle qu'on est sur
tous les fronts à la fois non pardon je
sais que tu as quitté donc on va te
laisser la merci beaucoup d'être venus
et pour une fois c'était très très
chouette et puis peut-être une prochaine
fois merci pour l'invitation merci de
m'avoir rencontré quelqu'un de
quelques-uns et d'avoir vu olivier
bompas sans contact aux problèmes
salut
moi j'avais une question par rapport au
revoir en fait si je me mets à la place
du joueur qui renvoyait en aura encore
j'ai été sélectionné par un x ou y et
qui peu importe on va en europe et on me
dit pas ce qu'on entend ça on sait que
ça se fait
les types te dis ta franchise j'ai envie
que tu pourrais sursis tel domaine tel
domaine tel domaine mais si par exemple
l'équipe dans laquelle j'arrive un autre
projet pour moi qui fait quoi comment
est-ce que le voir quelquefois les
badauds à une opposition qui entend un
peu tout et son contraire en fait
c'est pas si ma question est très
talentueux
grâce à
la prime blanche à la main en chantant
plus non non tu veux que je commence à
s'éveiller
olivier rené veillon et
enfin forcément le joueur et
vulgairement apparemment le cul entre
deux chaises parce que tu as ta les
attentes de la franchise et apec à la
réalité des équipes qui avaient des
résultats à faire est qu'aujourd'hui les
équipes françaises ne sont pas calibrés
et paramétrer uniquement pour développer
des joueurs parce qu'il ya des
impératifs de résultats que ce soit sur
les championnats nationaux et ce soir
sur les qualifications coup en coupe
d'europe que ce soit sur les chaises sur
les coupes d'europe qu'elle dispute et
que toute la subtilité pour une équipe
française en l'occurrence c'est
d'arriver à insérer ce projet la dent
dans son collectif elle alors elle y est
forcément
intéressés dans tous les sens du terme
puisque à faire financièrement il ya un
bail à un transfert qui et qui est payée
par la franchise nba vers l'âme équipes
européennes donc forcément elles jouent
le jeu mais mais il ya un ajustement
clairement à trouver entre le fait de
continuer à se développer par rapport à
ceux de man de la franchise et puis
aussi s'insérer dans un collectif de
gagner des matches ici sur un
championnat européen
qui n'est pas un système de ligue fermée
avec avec des protections de ce soit à
tous les étages donc c'est pas évident
moi si je peux rajouter par rapport à ça
c'est une question que pour en avoir
discuté avec certains collègues d'autres
équipes et on en a parlé entre nous en
interne avec le staff avant
l'intersaison dernière se poser la
question est ce qu'on va chercher un
jeune joueur à potentiel le problème
c'est que tu fais ça je parle pas là
joueurs en stage très sévèrement et je
parle vraiment d'un d'un projet de
développement sur un joueur si
aujourd'hui tu vas chercher un joueur au
potentiel drafté ou pas tu va
inévitablement on te retrouves avec
quelqu'un avec un agenda perso on nage
en apercevant dans sa façon de vouloir
évoluer qui va falloir que tu intègres à
ton projet collectif aujourd'hui que le
10 juillet sur le fonctionnement qu'on a
en europe sur la non protection qu'on a
sur nos championnats sur les adjectifs
sur peut-être choquer les gens mais sur
l'absence de projet d'énormément de deux
clubs et sur le fait que les dirigeants
et saab ont souligné qu'un agent ne
confirmera ya comme des gens qui ont des
visions à très très très très très court
terme qui sont qui vont à l'encontre de
toute notion de développement y compris
pour des joueurs qu'on aurait déjà
confirmé sur les contrats pluriannuels
et nibali c'est vraiment quelque chose
une vraie problématique aujourd'hui je
le comprends que les entraîneurs soit
free de se dire à l'idée de fin de mois
est de se dire tiens on va prendre un
jeune joueur ou alors on va prendre un
mec qui a été drafté qui vient chez nous
comme ça pour le développer ainsi de
suite c'est c'est quelque chose de très
compliqué j'avais sollicité là ce soir
jcpraz tal coat du paris basket ball
après qu'ils soient un petit peu avec
nous pour en parler il tait
malheureusement pas dispo mais lui l'a
vécu ça avec avec qu'ils aillent à
cordes signé à l'époque où il avait eu
droit cette draft il le vit cette année
avec jm bigard a donc ces scellés
question j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
de lui poser à l'occaz parce que bondues
part il ya quand même quelques jours
dans l'entrée et puis l'autre parilla
vive truc à lui ce truc là maintenant
puisque puisqu'il a un joueur en stage
chez lui moi je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est pas simple à gérer on
prend le cas la ligue australienne par
exemple ça va plus loin puisque en
australie on est presque sur un projet
de ligue c'est à dire que
la la nbl ccc développés s'est
développée économiquement et
sportivement sur plein d'aspects mais
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que les
joueurs les joueurs potentiels les vrais
prospects qui vont en australie le
contrat pour faire simple que pris en
charge par la ligue et moi je moi je moi
dans mon imaginaire de cause je le dis
c'est extraordinaire comme ça sauf que
quelque part ça résout une partie du
problème ça résume pression économique
ça résout certes un certain souci qu'on
peut avoir parce que les choses sont
sûrement plus facile à gérer comme ça il
ya d'autres problèmes en contrepartie
aujourd'hui celle où je pense pas qu'un
club est forcément les moyens de mettre
de mettre plus que ça sur un jeune
joueur en disant on va le développer que
cet arrêt que ces parages ça me parait
ça me paraît un petit peu illusoire
cesse et c'est très difficile à
appréhender mais parce que c'est s'est
passé par nombreux usages du tout et
puis parce qu'il pourquoi immédiate et
dont les résultats qui fait de toute
façon c'est pas ou peu compatibles c'est
pourquoi je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez est ce que la ligue australienne
n'avait pas aussi besoin de cette
stratégie là pour avoir un gros coup de
projecteur sur elle et prendre entre
guillemets un virage de développement de
deux succursales nba
comment la stratégie
la ligue avec d'autres méga besoin de ça
le nemesis a besoin de ça
tu parles tu pars deux clubs qui entre
guillemets
appartiennent à des agents
pour les gens de l'âge légal est max ça
veut dire cccc le projet bcb au basket
qui est derrière des vj c'est un
problème de yahia a mené un projet bien
désolé c'est l'émotion là-dessus
sûrement je veux dire chez je sais qu'en
france il ya il ya quelques minutes
quelques quelques idées des agences qui
vous laissiez d'être sûr en sur un
procès ce qu'ils soient eux mêmes je
juge pas du bien fondé ou pas du truc ça
peut être quelque chose de très
intéressant si c'est bien cadré c'est
comme tout mais on est sur des logiques
différentes là on est sur des logiques
de 2,2 dad agences qui sont là pour
faire avancer leur truc
dans le cas d'un cadre normal c'est
compliqué mais pour revenir sur la
question de la ligue australienne
aujourd'hui d'aller aux australiennes
elle a 20 millions d'euros de droits
télé elle a commencé sur twitch et sur
youtube elle est aujourd'hui sous
contrat mais qui espionnent parce que sa
visibilité de la gagner là dessus
autrement qu'avec des twins histoire de
pépites et compagnie bon voilà je fais
on n'a pas de diffuseur télé en france
ont produit des joueurs n'a pas
diffuseur télé alors oui c'est bien
c'est gratuit c'est partout sauf
qu'aujourd'hui notre championnat si la
ligue australienne car ce championnat
très bonne qualité arrive à intéresser
les lesquels quelques quelques
observateurs us et a récupéré un contrat
télé avec avec qui espionnent aux idées
des diffuseurs dans ce genre là je
n'arrive pas à concevoir moi que chez
nous alors que quelque part on a autant
de joueurs à développer et votants
potentiels comme australie sites les
plus
je sais que je sais que je souhaitais
que je me dirai ce que j'ai fait mais un
moment à l'autre c'est surréaliste mais
encore une fois moi comme j'ai souvent
je suis à la stratégie est le stratège
non il faut c'est parce qu'il faut
trouver un diacre et c'est un chose à
avant je crois et l'australie ils ont
isolé sable ils savent ce qu'ils vendent
depuis quelques années ils ont eu un
procès qui se met à table trois ils ont
mis le paquet dessus pendant quelques
années et c'est ce qu'ils ont bien fait
et cette année ils ont six ou sept
joueurs fois qu'ils sont venus d'europe
qui sont pas offerts grâce et donc on ne
sait pas dans le cadre d'un stage qui
sont pas faits encore drafté qu'elle
dans des clubs européens partout en
europe et qui vont finir leur cursus
leur cursus en de fer drafté aux états
en australie moi je pense c'est olivier
10 ha il ya une incompatibilité pour moi
entre développer des prospects de et
gagner être compétitif sur le plan
national ou européen je ne sais pas
parce que si tu regardes l'an dernier en
voyant le paris basket paris basket ball
parmi ces dames engueuler regarde
regarde dans le cas de leur équipe
pendant deux ans il a fait jouer il a
fait jouer comme ils s'appellent il a
fait jouer millan berbich il affirmé
gâtés l'an dernier julien mahé fait un
boulot extraordinaire avec hugo besson à
saint quentin
tu es quand même sur
ces en pro b oui enfin sauf que ces
sabots et on promet un moment donné j'ai
passé six ans prouver un donner les clés
du camion un gamin de 19 ans il faut
vouloir le faire aussi pour
ces deux équipes il ya un risque sauf
qu'encore une fois on est sûr y ait
d'autres projets club appartient goûter
dirigeants comprennent que tu as un gain
d'image alors tu me diras l'image c'est
parce qu'il fait bouffer c'est sûr mais
tu as un gain d'image tête et tu vas
valorisé quelque chose qu'on promet tu
peux le valoriser tu as un gain d'image
citons gain d'image se transforme en
gains sportif parce que quelque part tu
fais avancer les choses site amorce la
pompe comme ça tu crées aussi mis les
entités comme elle que beau aujourd'hui
à l'heure actuelle mon identité propre
sur la première et la deuxième chez nous
réelle et actuelle autre que en bas
tient il ya vingt ans la forme était le
joueur et elle jouera quatre joueurs
bien à peu je pense que là comme une
prise de risque et qui à tout club sont
pas prêts à le faire et pas des clubs
par contre comme jadis gérés par des
agents dont travail c'est de te prendre
de te mettre en avant pour que tu
montres tour si on veut que tu puisses
en gros joué 30 minutes par match et
même si tu fais des conneries tu sors
pas c'est ce qui arrive dans certains
clubs européens parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de tête nous raison peut-être moins la
pression du résultat que d'autres globe
dans d'autres ligues je pense que la
france est un juste milieu je pense que
c'est faisable je pense que c'est
faisable même sur des équipes
européennes et l'exemple du pari passé
vous n'est pas anodin tu as un président
qui est un qui était un américain qui a
annoncé general manager pareil cas une
possibilité de collaboration qui est qui
n'est pas la même personne fait sauf
qu'il a déjà fait et qui a déjà eu un
des joueurs avant siadat avait encore
dîner comme était à l'honneur je pense
qu'à un moment ça rassure aussi la
franchise à se dire ok il ya un
écosystème autour du joueur qui est
favorable qu'ont coin projet qui va être
ouvert à la collaboration et dans ce cas
de figure là tu peux te lancer dans
l'aventuré de coeur ont dit ok on sait
que douala va se développer au paris
basket et qu'ils vont respecter un petit
peu aussi qu'il ya des charges qu'on
pourrait leur donner quant à l'évolution
qu'on veut du joueur mais mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas en tout cas je pense
qu'il ya un juste milieu c'est que ça
mais c'était un système qui est
duplicable aux 18 équipes de betclic et
non c'est clairement pas possible il ya
des équipes que aujourd'hui sont une
urgence total de résultats
et quand bien même il ya mis le
potentiel manne financière à la clé
d'ici un an ou deux il ya déjà un
maintien assuré d'europe a essayé de se
qualifier voilà c'est compliqué moi
aujourd'hui sincèrement j'ai
et c'est difficile à expliquer aux
joueurs mais le graphène sache c'est une
solution qui est pour moi une solution
un peu cache misère en dix ans la
franchise ne va pas se débarrasser de
son pic parce que ce pic là il est
monnayable d'une façon ou d'une autre et
que tu peut l'intégrer dans un trade un
échange de joueurs dans un ou deux ans
et qu'à un moment quelques aujourd'hui
cette équipe n'a pas besoin de tels
types de joueurs mais que l'équipe qui
va vouloir trévé un genre de chez moi
aura besoin de file allemande de
quelques mecs pour le trait du caire
pour la sommellerie par contre pour un
joueur c'est vrai que
on touche du doigt le vrai problème il
ya des formes quelques allées la merci
des situations pour un joueur entre est
gras fait entre 45 et 60 par une
franchise qui va détenir les droits ad
vitam aeternam est plutôt finalement
presque ne pas être graffer et avoir
pendant les deux trois ans qui viennent
toutes les options sur la table et que
tu puisses finalement faire un trait
d'une quête une seule mairie avec une
équipe qui aura besoin d'agents dans ton
profil c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
et partirait de sachets de trois ans et
revenir dans la même franchise il sait
passer du temps entre temps il ya eu des
échanges de joueurs il ya une autre date
faut vraiment que le jour est
excessivement bon on parlait de wynau be
plus à leur nom pareil bogdanovic
masanovic tournhac affrontements une
relique de mec est archi dominant sur le
meilleur niveau européen c'est plus
facile pour revenir en nba et des fois
ils valent même pas y aller parce qu'ils
ne sont pas contents de l'appareil la
défense est fine et sur leur droit
l'exemple ses messages ses mécènes et ne
pas aller en europe et si c'était
quelqu'un de quelqu'un et gordini o'shea
il sert de monnaie d échange sur un
trade entre entre atlanta et et brooklyn
il ya quelques temps mots qui le fuit
depuis depuis ce moment là et puis bah
ils reconstruisent une équipe
aujourd'hui pour aller chercher un titre
le problème c'est qu'ils aillent à qui
légitimement on se disait j'ai pouvoir
pour chien le cap est allé chercher soit
un tout et soit éventuellement contrat
garantit aujourd'hui embouteillages la
franchise renonce à ses droits el mex le
mec alors qu'il était en stage plus plu
depuis sa draft se retrouve quelque part
alors qui n'est pas très loin de
franchir le cap sans finalement il
appartient qu il appartient les
personnes céderont été scellée donc
tueur je recommence un process
différents comme du holiday puisse ses
droits ce cd est évident il correspond
pas
me antoine gillot marché actuel parce
que aller chercher leur ligue
aujourd'hui sera peut-être moins bilan
aller chercher le rockeur dans quel
contexte et ainsi de suite et s'il
allait chauffer quelque chose sur un
trail inc m peut avoir une invitation
quelque part faut plus trop traîner
parce que c'est déjà bien avancé pour
tous donc tu sais quand même c'est quand
même pas c'est pas évident c'est
possible mais c'est sûr je reprends
toujours la phrase que me disait franck
à celle que que que j'avais eue mois à
boulazac et est lui passé par de mémoire
il a fait le training avec les spurs il
a dû passer par l'équipe de gimmicks de
des spurs et de sl de de cleveland il
racontait trendy clé dans les derniers
est en fait battre les spurs il boris
diaw dit je me retrouvais maurizio face
à moi pour le dernier spot donc
inévitablement je n'ai pas eu grand
chose à espérer je me suis retrouvé les
joies angélique derrière bas je me suis
dit adji bon ben c'est pas trop ce que
je veux il est parti en europe il m'a
dit j'ai réalisé à 5 26 ans le chihuahua
de façon si je fais mon taxi garé ma vie
ici puisque je suis suffisamment bon de
toute façon quelqu'un leveragés
retournerai parce que le maillage des
franchises nba aujourd'hui et tel que je
pense qu'un mec qui passe à travers
complet ça n'existe plus ça n'existe
plus vous alors c'est la faute à pas de
chance mais ça je ne vois pas comment
aujourd'hui c'est possible de passer
totalement au travers ou alors c'est
parce que mahut blessure a lieu ce qui a
eu sa il ya des causes externes ou des
causes des causes différentes mais je
vois pas comment aujourd'hui un joueur
qui se retrouveraient dominant au niveau
européen
par exemple ne pas ne pas avoir une
chance un jour quelque part
on a vu un petit peu par rapport
cost h qu'est ce que ce serait du coup
on a parlé de lisier kandinsky
mon point de vue en tout cas à
semble-t-il rempli toutes les conditions
finalement parce qu'il a prouvé c'est là
on l'attendait c'est un gars qui est
camille limite équipe de france
qui est souvent appelé
au dernier stage et qui pourtant là va
se retrouver sans club alors est-ce que
du coup on peut on est légitimement
inquiet pour joindre des gars à qui a
été drafté par les celtics l'été dernier
cesser ces points je pense pas que ce
soit nous le dire parce que hein mais
pour moi moi je personnel moi je suis
pas produit le dossier coup j'ai pas
bien ce que ce que lui et son agence a
lieu deux mois
moi je pense qu'après donc dans le cadre
de quatre jeunes peut-être que vu le
contexte de la rade de 7,2 points qui
vient de se passer est celle de l'année
prochaine
le regret c'est de se dire il entend
jeep élite et ce en attendant un an de
plus tu peux pas aller chercher du lait
de first sur la draft c'est d'être la
seule question mais aller vite
maintenant faire le film après film si
tu veux c'est presque idiot d'en parler
mais stratégiquement t'attends à nantes
plus est ce que tu es pas sur un contrat
garanti ça c'est la question que tu peux
tu peux tu peux peut-être te poser mais
derrière derrière l'exposition il va la
voir et pour le coup de manière plutôt
intéressante parce que très central
parce qu'à paris donc avec est une rampe
d'accès très facile pour les scouts avec
une façon d'évaluer qui sera ce qu'il
sera facilitée avec un lien comme le dit
olivier d'une vraie culture et ce au
niveau du management de chez eux avec
avec des gens qui sont aux états unis
donc le lien est très facile à faire
s'est passé ce n'est pas nécessairement
une mauvaise opération
après moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
urgent l'urgence pour pour jeunes c'est
le basket il ya le fait aussi de
s'adapter à l'anglais et d'haïti s'est
passé inquiète là dessus parce que je
pense que c'était aussi parmi les
petites choses que qui ont été pointés
sur sur sur son sur son été c'est qu'il
y avait il ya les stades appelation là à
voir après sur un champ parce qu est ce
qu il doit évoluer correctement il
évoluera correctement à boston suite
franchise qui évoque bien je pense pas
non plus qu'il soit débarrassé d'un tour
de draft sur un joueur comme ça à
potentiel européen au contraire après le
reste moi personnellement je suis pas
dans la confidence et je connais pas le
fond du fond du dossier donc répondre ça
me parait ça me paraît délicat
rappelle que vous pouvez poser vos
questions sur le tchat n'hésitez pas si
vous en avez c'est le moment on en
profite on et olivier qui hélas échos
donc si vous avez tout des
interrogations ou des doutes sur tout ce
qui se passe en coulisses dans les
contrats angie et pour les stages ou
peut-être aussi pour autre chose c'est
le moment d'en profiter je rappelle que
tout bientôt on va mettre à l'âne sur le
grill il va avoir
droit
un petit portrait concoctait maison et
puis après et sans doute comprendra
encore les dernières questions avant de
se séparer pour cette première émission
et on vient sur le draft eustache qu'est
ce qui serait un cadre idéal comme pour
un joueur qui se fait qu'ils connaissent
cette aventure là
je rejoins un peu ce que visait romain
peut être que paris peut être le cadre
idéal pour jouer à pékin parce que
une franchise qui est quand même axé sur
un développement à vitesse grand v les
quais base aussi sur l'éclosion de
prospects ça a été la marque de fabrique
depuis la création du club dont il ya
quand même un adn et de formation dans
ce club là il avait quand même depuis
deux ans la plus petite moyenne d'âge du
championnat de pro b c'est pas rien ils
sont montés avec cette équipe là donc je
pense que déjà il ya une équipe qui a
envie d'exposer ses joueurs et qu'il a
fait jusqu'à maintenant un coach dont
c'est aussi des marques fabriquent un
président qui connaît parfaitement les
rouages du de l'environnement aee
publiées donc je pense effectivement les
ingrédients clés c'est une parfait
possibilités de collaboration entre la
franchise et l'équipe localement qui
récupère le joueur est caché dans une
équipe tu vas jouer 10 minutes par ci
par là j'en vois pas l'intérêt là il y
aura pas de leurs pattes progression je
caricature un petit peu le propos mais
il y aura très peu de progression il y
aura très peu de d'intérêt à rester à
mon plus dans ce cas voilà autant aller
en ville il est resté à côté d'eux et
travailler physiquement non dans ce cas
de figure là un garçon comme megara va
avoir un rôle majeur
a paris sur un championnat qui qui est
quand même très valorisé au jeu de
l'ailier puisqu'il se rapproche des
standards athlétique et physique de
cette liga donc tu joues dans un
écosystème qui est un peu le même
commande était un joueur comme caillou
quid qui rejoint l'équipe qui est quand
même un ancien passé par la nba qui
connaît un petit peu le fonctionnement
donc je pense qu'il faut une cape à ses
collaborations aucune vraie place dans
la dans l'équipe avec un vrai potentiel
de temps de jeu et puis ensuite après et
bayard il ya un facteur il faut se dire
allez un facteur chance sur l'alignement
des planètes c'est à dire les besoins de
la franchise l'année prochaine sur ce
poste là et c'est après dans le cas d'un
garçon comme jeunes sur pareil il ya
deux types de drakan stage il ya
graphène stage compté dans sa première
année d'éligibilité à 19 ans et est
compté à 22 ans la table la projection
en termes de temps et de progression
n'est pas la même ex tâche et 1,19 bon
bah tu peux dire ok tu as besoin de
prendre de l'expérience a besoin des
fois que développer physiquement et
sachets à 22 ça sent déjà bon moment
pour me chercher là même
qui est il ya une remarque qui dit elle
la sig à 7h tchicamboud friche et
beaufort en pro b est ce que il n'ya pas
une et deux analogie à faire là ce que
c'est complètement
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient le même
salaire après mais
contrat de garantie nbc est le souci non
mais nous ne nous clairement pas le
choix il intéressant nounou clermont
avait commencé la saison dernière avec s
e melli m qu'on avait qu'on avait mis en
double licence à côté de chez nous à
souffel parce que en étant 11/12 sur une
rotation avec derrière plusieurs
d'étrangers il était pour nous un petit
peu un petit peu dommage qu'ils trouvent
pas de minutes donc on doit être les
buts comme ça cette année dans le cadre
dans lequel du cabot fort la question
s'était posée devant olivier connaît le
dossier pour en parler mieux que moi
mais dans le cas du cadeau fort c'était
quoi rester en espoirs ou allait prendre
deux minutes en pro b je pense que la
question la question la réponse est
évidente vaut mieux les prendre et 8 en
pro b surtout dans un contexte aix
maurienne pourriez de passe et qui est
parfois particuliers mais très formateur
dans le cas de jason c'était pareil
prendre des minutes parce qu'à un moment
il a il a besoin le terrain il a montré
des choses qui étaient déprimés
intéressante à la coupe du monde cet été
là en u19 il s'est montré plusieurs fois
par séquences l'an dernier avec le monde
y est guetté également suite au suite
aux blessures et à ya des moments où
tout simplement d'abord de lui faire
confiance et puis dans le cadre dans le
cas de clément ben le championnat
espoirs je pense il a porté plus grand
chose c'est un joueur qui a besoin
d'avoir un petit peu de un petit peu de
diversité de lyon en face de lui j'ai
envie de dire parce que j'en un peu de
dureté et un petit peu encore un petit
short pour pour le niveau auquel on
était surtout une envie pour nous et
pour le directeur sportif qui qui gère
la boutique chez nous à nicolas alberny
ne veut pas de faire en sorte que les
jeux de joie et des minutes pour voir si
à court et moyen terme s'il ya des gens
qui peuvent revenir chez nous avec un
statut différent et capacité à jouer
l'idée elle est plutôt que de bloquer
les gens et de ne pas laisser de ne pas
les laisser on va dire pouvoir
s'exprimer sur le terrain parce que les
embouteillages et parce que on aussi des
objectifs de résultats tout simplement
d'un moment donné un tour et
aix-maurienne c'était des solutions très
intéressante et pérenne avec dans les
trois cadets les entraîneurs qui
connaissent très bien la division b lire
manu schmitt ça fait plusieurs saisons
que celle à aix maurienne qui bosse très
bien rallier vers la à denain on ne
présente plus et un c'est un taulier de
la division et puis pierre tavano à tour
c'est pareil ce que je connais très bien
le travail et le niveau français qui
était longtemps à des passants coller
ici donc dans les trois-quarts nous
envoie les joueurs dans les contextes où
on sait que ça se passera bien carillo
carrick fait mais bien la question moi
je trouve qu'elle est pertinente et
l'exemple finalement ces trois jeunes là
une source dossier du caveau fort je
connais bien pour le représenter je
trouvais ça illustre parfaitement les
besoins et les ingrédients dont tu tu
parlais tout à l'heure pour la réussite
d'un stage séquence est là c'est
vraiment du gagnant gagnant dans le cas
l'udc avoir comme le dit très justement
romain est face à un joueur qui
finalement est ce le début d'un gratin
de sa fédération qui était déjà on va
dire un joueur plus que 2000 en
championnat soit l'intérêt pour si on
l'illustrent parlement franchi en tout
cas pour l'équipe de strasbourg c'est de
se dire on le met dans un contexte qui
va continuer à lui permettre de se
développer de progresser et moi en tant
qu'équipe site strasbourg j'ai toutes
les chances de récupérer au bout d'un an
joueur qui est plus près du mur et dont
je serais vraiment s'il est apte à nez
sur le très haut niveau donc si on remet
ça dans le contexte d'une franchise nba
c'est de trouver le club qui va être dit
mais de permettre d'évaluer ce garçon là
sur un niveau de compétition plus élevé
que si j'avais votre guise et laissé sur
peut-être parfois une équipe de geely
qui dit qu'il n'y a pas d'obligation de
résultat là en tout cas je lui mettre
dans l'adversité je vais le mettre dans
la compétition et enfin à la fin de
l'année je vais pouvoir juger de son
évolution physique technique mental et
il me dire ok est ce qu'il est prêt
maintenant à passer ferté venir avec
nous ou est ce qu'il aura besoin d'une
deuxième année généralement romain tu
verras si je me trompe c'est évidemment
concrétisée par une participation en
summer league qui valide les progrès ou
pas on est très très souvent très
souvent c'est ça même les mecs qui sont
qui sont en stage plusieurs saisons font
très souvent la summer league ou alors
il me semble que c'était notre camarade
christian corderas cela qu'ils
s'occupent qui s'occupent des espoirs en
type qui a notamment dû passer entre ses
reins qui n tilly
comment timothée louer ou ennemis qui
l'a examiné
lui expliquer qu'il ya parfois même sur
des sur des périodes hors saison sur
trouvea les différents endroits en
europe aux seuils légaux janet y étaient
partie je suis plus là c'est beau c'est
en espagne avec
je ne sais plus quel quelques autres
juste absurde et sur des séquences
précises il ya toujours des moments où
la franchise en fait elle à elle à une
évaluation permanente de ces de ses
commandes hier de ces deux de ses
joueurs draftés qu'ils restent dans leur
pays ou qui restent en sache quelque
part c'est pour ça que je voyais un
commentaire tout à l'heure de quelqu'un
de flaminio tu disais que begarin les
déclaré que que boston est déjà du doigt
les franchises regarde en permanence sur
l'évaluation n'est pas juste j'aime pas
de bord de 13 octobre puis le 14 mars
c'est à dire qu'il ya vraiment lille une
évaluation longitudinal et et qui permet
justement de suivre ça correctement donc
ya pas de pour moi ya pas de hasard si
rare qu'un joueur qui en stage s'il ne
retarde pas d'une raison aussi
qu'elle soit contractuels ou qu'elles
soient liées au non deux comme comme
comme le cas lisez cording deux joueurs
sous contrat ou c'est parce que
sportivement la franchise pense que le
mec n'a pas forcément passer le caté
il va pas forcément plus loin que des
invitations lui en summer league autres
et puis parce que dernier point les
calendriers aimiez correspond pas du
tout aux d'autres c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui un joueur français qui
veut partir à l'étranger c'est déjà pas
évident parce que chez nous en france
les marchés sont très tôt par rapport à
la turquie l italie espagne où les
choses se décantent plus tard le marché
de bié gens pas c'est à dire qu' il
faudrait qu'un joueur français prennent
le risque aujourd'hui d'être sans
contraintes sur le début de saison pour
tenter le coup sûr sur un sur un camp
d'entraînement avec une franchise nba
sans savoir sur un contrat garanti puis
sans trop savoir ce qu'il ya derrière
après une prise de risque qui est plus
ou moins calculable et anticipable mais
jamais de certitudes encore une fois la
franchise elle décide si vous gagne au
loto ou pas et avec le co vie ces
décalages de calendrier encore plus
important parce qu'on fait toute la
saison et billets a été décalé dans le
temps par contre la saison finalement de
décisions européennes terminé à une à
deux semaines près au même moment d'un
espace de temps entre mi juin et
finalement les traits du cap
mi-septembre long des deux mois tout se
passe par là donc c'est compliqué alors
fait effectivement réussi à trouver
je précise juste et christian et yamaha
team envoyer la formation qu'il manquait
donc c'était bien il avait coordonné par
ty bos en espagne avec pablo prigioni
en saison hors saison dans le cas du
duché brooklyn avait dû à ce moment là
[Musique]
messieurs est ce qu'on a fait le tour de
la question risque qu on aille à des
points qu'on n'a pas abordé je crois
qu'on était assez complet sur ce dossier
on a parlé
des conditions dans laquelle se passer
un stage les conditions idéales
pourquoi en fait finalement ça marchait
pas et en partie parce que bahia
l'apparition des to et aider voir qu'ils
sont au final plus près des franchises
et que les franchises ont plus de
facilité à avoir aussi des coachs à
mettre et c'est
donc je pense qu'on a été assez complet
sur sur la sphère du brassens tâche
va s'occuper du cas d'alan bientôt
olivier est ce que tu peux relire et
restez avec nous pour la fin d'émission
où tu dois y aller aussi vers les coûts
d'achat savez vous habituer occasion
rien son aîné mais le piratage des
applications
alan est maintenant c'est parti
c'est un portrait que j'ai intitulé un
portrait smasher coucou france tv alors
question 1 il ya pas de questions à nos
questions donc je ça doit aller vite un
hashtag envergure l'envergure pardon et
ville où tu habites
25 ans paris on verra l'urgent c'est pas
m 89 ans à 92,2 rennes se comptent en
meubles en armoire sous la halle 09
armoires de la harmoye bassil bien
entendu comme l'étude 22 basket
c'est mon père qui m'a montré des modes
quand j'étais petit parce qu'il a été à
la fois que en californie les années 90
situé tire la geste technique au basket
tu serais quoi
un finger roll
pouvoir qui t'a le plus marqué et
pourquoi
pas le pire non kevin garnett parce que
c'est le meilleur poste 4 de tous les
temps
à la une petit hôtel j'aime bien si tu
étais coach tu serais et pourquoi à un
moment ouais
[Musique]
peu importe un endroit peu n'importe où
moi je connais moi en europe
je ferai je ferais
night haute le coach d'alabama mais
calme attendait john calipari je suis
déçu
la meilleure équipe que tu as vu jouer
en vrai
[Musique]
c'est une bonne question à mille milles
en d'ettore messina ouais
ok l'année du goût rappelle que voilà
donc trois semaines deux ou trois
semaines si tu étais un logo d'apple du
basket tu serais celtics celtics ont
clubs français préférés là tu va diviser
des gens savaient intéressant
[Musique]
sur le logo antilles
je sais pas si mon avenir pour le logo
et le soleil
donc ta franchise nba préféré ici et là
encore un doute boston voilà un bon ton
programme healthy préféré
santé complets scanner comment san diego
state 110 combine
un mot pour décrire le basket face à
vous un adjectif
[Musique]
athlétique la stac la plus importante
selon toi
le rapport aux taux d'usagé trouche
routine
mais tout est aussi la réponse un réseau
social ou de suivre twitter
twitter j'espérais que tous nous relance
sont snapshot mais poussé par la qualité
chez les lourds comme tu le regardes le
plus c'est lui avec lt plus attaché
un peu ton vi
[Musique]
ça dépend du poste
j'ai par le premier la qualité
athlétique le premier pas ouais ok le
défaut quasi éliminatoire chez un joueur
contre toi quand tu regardes un mois à
l'inter qui peut pas défendre
comme en ville devant un match de basket
en pleine nuit
du fromage blanc
le mec fringe et son live ok la plus
grande où tu as passé beaucoup de temps
plus grande en bas de chez moi métro
pernety dans le 14ème arrondissement de
paris ok trois personnes étaient basket
avec qui tu aimerais échanger autour
d'un verre
romain
comme un verre ça va être autour d'un
verre ça va être compliqué mais au père
n'y a pas de problème à
[Musique]
personne
lebron james
et 7 qu'obradovic
hockey un aspect du jeu qui se sentent
sous-estimé
ou son côté
paris
j'ai souvent sous cotées hors terrain et
je me rends compte de plus en plus que
c'est important dans l'évaluation du
prospect
un aspect du jeu qui te semble
surestimée surcoté pour les coûts
l'adresse brut à trois points l'adresse
de brut à trois points n'est cependant
que fais tu dans la vie actuellement
quel est ton métier ou des études plus
je me permets mon master en science
politique et
sociologie américaine je suis
surveillant dans un wc
alors là une autre question qui va clivé
team pains au chocolat baisser ou
étoiles de la chocolatine
même pas les viennoiseries mais je veux
dire point je veux dire qu'on joue quoi
donc c est si tu étais un fromage tu
serais
je ferai du cantal et pourquoi
d'ailleurs qui serions c'est trop bon
parce que c'est trop bobo dans la course
ce qui stoppe le roumain
à une question à poser du genre
non non non je suis spectateur il faut
que je rentre pas dans ces débats là
bon on va prendre les dernières
questions sur le chat et puis après on
va gentiment que orelsan avait laissé
encore un stage pendant parce que c'est
ce que pieter cornelis encore un stage
en 2016 ouais ouais je n avais qu
il est là il a signé il a signé un
contrat l'a d'ailleurs d'éleveurs et
d'éleveurs il achemine un trader
il y avait une question si je crois
qu'on t'a est ce qu'il ya des prospects
intéressant dans la overtime
l'inra de 3 pouces super jeune et qu'on
les a pas trop trop vu jouer mais oui
pour recruter des joueurs extrêmement
intéressant
et moi j'ai la chance de voir alexandre
ça en vrai enfin mort terrain et oui il
a le profil pour être prometteur mais
s'il est né en 2005 il faut pas mettre
trop et la charrue avant les boeufs il y
serait allé jusqu'en 2024
il ya quelqu'un qui demande un mot sur 6
d'ici ce coup c'est une question qui
gère revenir au plus depuis le début de
l'émission il a fait le u18 avec
l'équipe de france arrête tel aviv et
joua bas se cogna je crois oui mon
espagne et oui c'est un c1 2004 moi
j'aime beaucoup le jeu mais un profil
athlétique il paraîtrait je n'ai pas vu
andré même très robuste pour sa part sa
taille et c'est un vrai phénomène
critiques après j'ai jamais vu jouer en
vrai il ya de plus en plus de jeunes
joueurs sur ces projets qui partent
qu'ils partent en espagne qui parle très
tôt aux états unis il quelques cassures
des chaussures des pays autres également
il ya je pense qu'à d'aller hors bitume
questions de fond pour le basket
français
a comme on dire à appréhender à traiter
correctement si on veut pas se retrouver
avec une espèce de de suite constante de
prospects après les raisons pour
lesquelles les gens partent leur
appartiennent et par là pour juger mais
en moment je pense que ça devrait
interpeller ça ne fait pas encore et
j'ai peur que au dessus de nous ça
réagisse dix ans trop tard
alexa ivan
traoré ousmane zaré
xemple mais à l'ubo besson je veux dire
moi si hugo c'est un joueur de talent
qui partent et qui part comme australie
pour une expérience et pour s'exposer
jeu je comprends tout à fait mais
dommage que les joueurs comme ça n'est
pas de la place pour louer pour une
ligne on tue il a montré qu'ils
pouvaient jouer en pro b sans aucun
souci après encore une fois je suis pas
donné dans les secrets dans les détails
des contrats des négociations une idée
les tractations et compagnie à titre
perso tant qu'entraîneur je trouve
toujours dommage lewarde et les
prospects des prospects de qualité s'en
aller parce que
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça qu'on
renouvelle un petit peu le réservoir de
joueurs qu'on a appuyé c'est moi je
pense que ça encore une fois ça doit
soulever des questions sur un vrai
problème de fond sur la gestion des
jaloux quand
est-ce qu'on a encore des questions sur
les 10 kg at on confié profitez en on va
bientôt fermer la boutique les gens du
petit info la queue que le délai qui
était que la france était avec la serbie
le joueur qui avait le plus de on
s'attache au niveau nationalité c'est
toujours toujours intéressant toujours
l'opération a précisé aussi
c'est vrai que les français sont des
noirs qui s'exporte
et bien messieurs je pense qu'on va
arrêter là et 22h contrat rempli on a
duré deux heures tout va bien mme
olivier un gros merci d'être venu nous
d'abord rejoindre pour cette erreur
c'était très sympa
et puis ben alla noro main
messieurs je vous dis à bientôt j'ai
beaucoup de remerciements à faire en
cette fin d'émission
donc c'est comme ça que le premier ep
draft 2021-2022 s'achève merci nous a
reçus jusqu'au bout n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner à la chaîne activer la
cloche et consulter régulièrement notre
site envergure princes et aux gros
remerciements à tous les invités
présents qui ont été un petit peu les
cobayes de cette nouvelle formule appel
qui est là olivier antoine
merci à toute l'équipe envergure ce
présent ce soir donc à la nique aux
romains on pense fort aussi à ben manu
et alex on verra sans doute bientôt un
shootout à toute la data team qui
travaille toujours dans l'ombre et bien
antoine juliens du xive maxime pierre b
et yacine petit nouveau qui s'occupera
le lobe le portail justement la g league
hélas une bielle un beau programme et on
n'oublie pas antoine qui gère le site
dont nombre et non et dans mercy et
appartenait à l'ats alex pour sa
confiance et pour son aide à préparer
cette émission même s'il est à l'autre
bout du monde
pour finir une pensée pour etienne et jb
de podcasts transatlantique bientôt une
nouvelle saison de popstars dingue et de
ficelle félicitations à jp leur papa
pour la deuxième fois depuis quelques
jours on se retrouve le mois prochain
avec un nouvel épisode de planer draft
d'ici là portez vous bien et à bientôt
salut salut
salut